Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum letzten Donnerstag im Monat. Und zwar eines ungeraden Monats. Und das bedeutet Chaosradio im Blue Moon hier auf Fritz. Und Chaosradio heißt, da sind Leute vom Chaos Computer Club und reden mit uns über Dinge, die irgendwie mit diesem Internet und der Digitaltechnik zu tun haben. Alles Sachen, die nicht mehr weggehen werden wahrscheinlich. Herzlich willkommen zum vielleicht letzten Chaos Radio dieses Jahr. Vielleicht aber auch nicht. Und auch das ist ein Thema, das wir später in der Sendung besprechen werden. Jetzt erstmal herzlich willkommen aus dem Chaos Computer Club Danimo. Carina. Matthias.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend zusammen.
Und Sokrates. So, normalerweise ist es ja so, so ein Chaos Radio hat ein Thema, das in voller Länge und Breite ausgewälzt, anerklärt und durchgenommen wird und dann hinterher klar ist. Heute ist das nicht so. Heute haben wir einen bunten Themenstrauß, einen Mix. Warum ist das so? Hat da jemand eine Antwort drauf? Oder ist das einfach nur, weil das Jahr, weil 2016 eh schon so durcheinander war, dann können wir jetzt auch aufhören, dieses einzelne Thema zu behandeln. Wir haben einfach so viel auf der Platte. Da müssen wir mal über ein paar Sachen reden.
Einfach mal ein bisschen Hausmeisterthemen abarbeiten.
Hausmeisterthemen, aha gut. Das ist also insbesondere zu den ersten beiden Themen, die wir sprechen werden. Das ist eine interessante Beschreibung. Mir ist es tatsächlich so gegangen, es nähert sich ja die Weihnachtszeit. Wir werden heute auch über Weihnachtsgeschenke sprechen. Es wird wirklich bunt. Und was ich euch noch sagen wollte, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, falls ihr zwischendurch Fragen habt, denkt so Moment, das ging mir zu schnell. Mehrere Themen, ja, aber das möchte ich noch mal genauer wissen. Könnt ihr gerne anrufen 0331 77 97 110. Wir erklären das trotzdem in Ruhe, bis es jeder verstanden hat. Und apropos Weihnachtsgeschenke, es ist ja auch wieder die Zeit, wo alle Leute sagen, hey, Jahreszeit gibt, spendet, gibt gut. Also die Wikipedia macht es gerade auf eine Art und Weise, man denkt, hey, kann mal bitte jemand die Werbung wegmachen. Andere machen das ein bisschen dezenter. Netzpolitik fragt zum Beispiel gerade wieder, hey, wir bloggen hier für euch, vielleicht wird uns Geld geben. Und da ist ein neuer Name aufgetaucht. Die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte. Was ist das denn? Hab so geguckt. Da sind so ein paar übliche Verdächtige, die man auch in diesem Kontext einordnen könnte. Also Malte Spitz zum Beispiel, der grünen Politiker, der mal die Vorratsdatenspeicherung sehr schön illustriert hat, indem er seine Daten veröffentlicht hat, die da gesammelt wurden. Volker Tripp von der Digitalen Gesellschaft, so eine Lobby-Organisation für Netzaktivisten oder Netzpolitik, könnte man sagen. Und Ulf Buermeyer, eigentlich ein Richter am Schwur gerichtet. So ein schönes Wort, aber auch in der Netzpolitik-Szene sehr aktiv. Und jetzt bei uns über Skype dazugeschaltet. Hallo und guten Tag. Als ob wir nicht genug Leute im Studio hätten.
Guten Abend.
So, es gibt jetzt also eine Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte.
Warum?
Ja, ganz einfach, weil unser Grundgesetz eine Rechtsschutzversicherung braucht. Das ist so der Slogan, den wir uns überlegt haben, weil wir doch in den letzten Jahren die Erfahrung gemacht haben, dass der parlamentarische Betrieb alleine nicht mehr dafür sorgt, dass Gesetze, die zum Beispiel der Bundestag schreibt, auch mit den Grundgesetzen überhaupt vereinbar sind. Aus verschiedensten Gründen, vielleicht reden wir gleich noch drüber, klappt das irgendwie nicht mehr so ganz, dass die Abgeordneten selber darauf achten, dass nicht zu hart in Grundrechte eingegriffen wird. Ein besonders krasses Beispiel ist, denke ich, jetzt das BND-Gesetz. Und zugleich ist es nicht so ganz einfach, dafür zu sorgen, dass solche Gesetze angegriffen werden. Also zum Beispiel kann man Verfassungsbeschwerden erheben nach Karlsruhe zum Bundesverfassungsgericht. Aber das ist eben ziemlich komplex. Also da braucht man Geld dafür, da braucht man Leute, dafür die das machen. Und das haben ja NGOs immer schon mal probiert.
Das ist sehr schnell. Also wir haben ja also Gewaltenteilung in Deutschland. Also unter anderem Leute, die dafür zuständig sind, Gesetze zu machen. Und diese Gesetze sollen im Grunde genommen das Grundgesetz beachten.
Ja, das sollen sie nicht nur, das müssen sie. Denn natürlich dürfen Parlamente nur Gesetze erlassen, die mit dem Grundgesetz vereinbar sind.
Und das passiert nicht immer?
Das passiert nicht immer. Das haben wir ja vom Bundesverfassungsgericht zum Beispiel, aber manchmal auch von Landesverfassungsgerichten schon öfters zu lesen bekommen, dass bestimmte Gesetze nicht mit dem Grundgesetz vereinbar sind. Beispielsweise die erste Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder nehmen wir das BKA-Gesetz. Da gab es jetzt im April 2016 eine Entscheidung aus Karlsruhe, das BKA-Gesetz. Das war auch in ganz vielen Punkten nicht mit dem Grundgesetz vereinbar. Das kommt also immer wieder vor, dass Gesetze sich nicht quasi an die Spielregeln halten und wir wollen dafür sorgen, dass solche Gesetze in einer sehr professionellen Weise nach Karlsruhe oder zu anderen Gerichten getragen werden und dort hoffentlich gekippt werden.
Bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, was zum Beispiel so ist, da haben sich ganz viele Leute zusammengetan, haben einen Anwalt beauftragt und haben, sagen, auch öffentlichen Druck erzeugt und also auch wenn es zwischendurch dann manchmal so ist, ja, irgendwie Bundesverfassungsgericht, unsere letzte Hoffnung, nur dort wird das Grundgesetz geachtet, hat sich es für mich bis jetzt schon so angefühlt, wie das wäre, es ist eine Ausnahme eigentlich. Also das passiert halt ab und zu im politischen Betrieb, aber das ist jetzt nicht so, dass man eine eigene Gesellschaft gründen muss. Das ist schon, also warum braucht es denn jetzt eine eigene Gesellschaft und warum macht man es nicht wie sozusagen bis jetzt, dass man sagt, okay, wenn es so eine Ausnahme gibt, dann finden wir uns schon irgendwie alle zusammen.
Ja, weil das mit diesen mit diesen Ausnahmen, glaube ich, einfach nicht stimmt. Es ist so, dass bislang nur ausnahmsweise geklagt werden konnte, einfach weil es ein riesen Aufwand war, nur aus einem konkreten Anlass heraus so eine Klage auf die Bane zu stellen. Da muss man ja, wie gesagt, zunächst mal das Geld zusammenbringen. Man muss dann auch Leute finden, die das machen und das ist nicht so ganz einfach. Also nehmen wir zum Beispiel eine der Verfassungsbeschwerden damals gegen die Vorratsentsprechung, die ist ja zum Beispiel von Meinheitsstereostik geschrieben worden. Der ist eigentlich vor allem Anwalt für Steuerrecht. Der ist zwar seit vielen Jahren engagiert, sagen wir so im weitesten Feld in linken Kontexten, aber der ist eigentlich kein Verfassungsrechtler gewesen. Der hat sich dann da reingefuchst und andere Leute haben ihm geholfen. Aber das ist jetzt eigentlich nicht so der erste, an den man denkt, wenn es darum geht, nach Karlsruhe zu gehen. Oder jedenfalls war es damals noch nicht. Und ich denke, das zeigt schon, wie doch viele Initiativen einfach sehr spontan zustande gekommen sind. Und da musste man unglaublichen Aufwand reinstecken. Und wir wollen einfach dafür sorgen, dass das professionalisiert wird und eben nicht nur gelegentlich klappt, sondern zuverlässig, sodass also wirklich jedenfalls können wir nicht sofort jetzt schaffen, aber dass auf Dauer wirklich alle Gesetze, die massiv Grundrechte verletzen, auch konsequent angegriffen werden.
Also ist da schon sozusagen auch die Idee, dass man politischen Druck macht, also im Sinne von wenn die gesetzgebenden Menschen wissen, es gibt jetzt eine eigene Organisation, die auf nichts anderes wartet als auf das neue Gesetz zu gucken und sozusagen zu schauen, ob man da was machen muss, dass dann sozusagen gleich bei der Gesetzgebung besser gearbeitet wird?
Das ist natürlich quasi unser Fernziel, dass jeder, der in einem parlamentarischen Gremium eine Entscheidung trifft, wo er eigentlich weiß, oh, das ist vermutlich nicht so ganz sauber, was wir da machen, dass der eben nicht mehr hoffen kann, das wird schon gut gehen. Vielleicht merkt es ja keiner, sondern dass man wirklich in dieser Situation ganz sicher weiß, was immer wir hier tun, es wird sehr professionell angegriffen werden. Und das gilt ja zum Beispiel auch auf Ebene der Bundesländer. Also wenn überhaupt bislang Gesetze angegriffen wurden, dann ging es da fast ausschließlich um Gesetze auf Bundesebene. Also ich kann mich jedenfalls nicht erinnern an irgendwie ein Fundraising, um ein Landesgesetz zu kippen. Aber auch Landesgesetze können massiv im Grundrecht eingreifen. Also um ein schönes Beispiel zu nennen, der Freistaat Bayern hat vor einigen Monaten ein besonders krasses Verfassungsschutzgesetz auf den Weg gebracht, das also eine ganze Reihe von Schmankerl enthält, wo man sich sehr sicher sein kann, dass die zum Beispiel in Karlsruhe wohl nicht halten würden. Aber in Bayern jedenfalls gab es bislang keine Initiative, um dagegen vorzugehen. Und wir wollen auch mal schauen, ob die GFF das nicht zum Beispiel tun kann.
Und du hattest gerade gesagt, ihr wollt das professionell machen. Das heißt, es ist tatsächlich so, dass unvorsichtig oder möglicherweise nicht vollständig korrekt formulierte Klagen dann auch durchfallen und man dann quasi seine Schwänze vom Verfassungsgericht verwirkt hat?
So sieht es aus. Man muss sehen, dass nur wenige Prozent von Verfassungsbeschwerden Erfolg haben. Also teilweise sind es sogar weniger als ein Prozent. Es hängt so ein bisschen davon ab, welchen Typ man sich anschaut. Die allermeisten bleiben erfolglos, weil das eben einfach sehr, sehr schwer ist. Und da denke ich, macht es schon Sinn, dass man eine Organisation aufbaut, die sich darauf spezialisiert hat. Und es geht aber auch um die Finanzierung. Es hat ja immer schon immer wieder mal zum Beispiel auch Crowdfunding-Aktionen gegeben, um Gerichtsentscheidungen anzugreifen. Also zum Beispiel, wenn die Zensurkammer am Landgericht Hamburg mal wieder eine besonders bizarre Entscheidung getroffen hatte, dann, ich erinnere mich an einen Fundraising, das, glaube ich, Markus Kompa mal gestartet hat, der Anwalt aus Westdeutschland. Ja, und dann löste sich dieser Fall irgendwie in Wohlgefallen auf, weil es sich irgendwie anders geklärt hatte. Und dann lagen da, ich weiß nicht, 20.000 Euro und niemand wusste mehr so richtig, wohin damit. Und das finden wir eigentlich schade. Also wenn man schon Geld sammelt aus der Community zum Beispiel für die Meinungsfreiheit, dann sollte das Geld dann ja auch auf jeden Fall für diesen Zweck genutzt werden. Und wenn es halt eine Organisation gibt, die konsequent klagt in solchen Fällen, dann kann man sicher sein, dass die Spenden auch auf jeden Fall für einen guten Zweck verwendet werden.
Ist das die, ob wir reden bei solchen Klagen, dass es dann sofort irgendwie fünfstellig wird?
Na gut, man muss sich überlegen, dass da sehr gute Juristen oder Juristinnen, wir haben auch natürlich Juristinnen beauftragt, jedenfalls einige Wochen daran arbeiten. Und dann ist es eben einfach so, dass man da nicht mit 2000 Euro dabei ist, normalerweise. Das muss man so deutlich sagen, wobei wir es bislang geschafft haben, dass eigentlich alle unsere Prozessvertreterinnen und Prozessvertreter uns sehr faire Preise gemacht haben, deutlich unterhalb des Marktpreises für eine Verfassungsbeschreibung.
Aber jetzt, ich meine, irgendwo auch gelesen zu haben, dass man, wenn man so eine Klage macht, dann erst mal so Geld fürs Gericht auch vorschießen muss.
Hat das auch was damit zu tun?
Das hängt so ein bisschen davon ab, wo man hingeht. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht selber erhebt keine Gerichtsgebühren. Da geht es vor allem um die Kosten natürlich der Prozessvertretung. Aber wir brauchen natürlich auch ein bisschen Geld für die Infrastruktur. Also bislang machen das die paar Gründer so quasi in ihrer Freizeit. Aber das skaliert natürlich nicht. Also wenn wir auf Dauer wirklich Verfassungsbeschwerden oder auch zum Beispiel Klagen vor anderen Gerichten erheben wollen, dann brauchen wir einen kleinen Apparat, also ein Büro, einige wenige Mitarbeiter, die sich um Spenden kümmern, Buchhaltung und natürlich auch um die Koordination der Klagen. Und auch das müssen wir jetzt über die Spenden, die wir für Klagen gewinnen, natürlich refinanzieren.
Okay, also in der Hoffnung, dass es nicht so viele Fälle wie Fragezeichenfolgen gibt, die ihr dann irgendwie anfangen müsst. Jetzt hast du das BND-Gesetz irgendwie erwähnt. Ist das sozusagen das erste, was jetzt angehen wollt?
Genau. Also wir haben ja jetzt gerade in der vergangenen Woche eine Verfassungsbeschwerde schon vorgestellt. Da geht es auch um die Arbeit des BND. Allerdings nicht um das BND-Gesetz, sondern das sogenannte G10. Diese Verfassungsbeschwerde ist jetzt schon eingereicht. Das haben wir zusammen gemacht mit Amnesty International, der deutschen Sektion, die da sehr gut mit uns zusammen gearbeitet haben. Aus dem Umfeld von Amnesty kommen auch die Beschwerdeführer. Genau. Und das war jetzt quasi BND Teil 1. Und der zweite große Teil wäre dann das BND-Gesetz, das jetzt gerade beschlossen ist und in Kürze in Kraft treten soll. Und das dem BND ja letztlich praktisch alle rechtlichen Regelungen abnimmt oder alle rechtlichen Grenzen abnimmt. Das führt aus meiner Sicht jedenfalls zu einer ziemlichen Entfesselung des BND. All das, was im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss als problematisch erkannt worden ist, soll einfach legalisiert werden. Und da bleibt letztlich vom Fernmeldegeheimnis, vom Telekommunikationsgeheimnis nichts mehr übrig. Und deswegen sind wir der Meinung, dass es jetzt ein ganz wichtiger Moment ist, um zu sagen, gegen dieses Gesetz müssen wir in Karlsruhe vorgehen. Und das koordiniert die GFF und mit einer relativ breiten Koalition von NGOers wahrscheinlich schon. Wer das ganz genau sein wird, können wir noch nicht sagen. Aber jedenfalls sind wir da auf keinen Fall Einzelkämpfer, sondern eine ganze Reihe von anderen Gruppen werden da wohl mitmachen. Also in den nächsten Wochen sehr regelmäßig, weil wir einfach jetzt ja eine ganze Weile schon Fälle vorbereitet haben. Ich denke aber, dass wir alle paar Wochen auf jeden Fall eine Verfassungsbeschwerde vorstellen, vielleicht, wenn sich das gut entwickelt, bald im Monatstakt. Also es ist leider so, dass sehr, sehr viele Gesetze mit den Grundrechten nicht vereinbar sind. Und wie gesagt, viele wurden bislang nicht angegriffen oder erst dann angegriffen, wenn sie im Einzelfall angewendet wurden. Aber das ist eben auch häufig schwierig. Und wie gesagt, wir wollen einfach sicherstellen, dass unser Grundgesetz eine Rechtsschutzversicherung hat, auf die man bauen kann.
Jetzt, dass ihr von der Idee total überzeugt seid, leuchtet ein. Aber wie sind denn so die Reaktionen von den Fachkollegen, sag ich mal?
Ja, also ehrlich gesagt sind die Reaktionen wirklich großartig. Wir sind völlig überwältigt von der Zahl an Fördermitgliedern, die wir gewonnen haben, ganz kurzfristig. Wir haben sehr viele positive Reaktionen auch aus der Justiz bekommen, also von Richterinnen und Richtern, die sagen, ja, ich habe hier auch einen Fall und ich würde mir so wünschen, wenn ihr den mal professionell aufrollt, das geht doch überhaupt nicht, was hier läuft. Wir haben auch ganz viele Zuschriften bekommen von Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftlern, also vor allem natürlich aus der Rechtswissenschaft, die gesagt haben, ja, das finde ich großartig, möchte bei euch mitmachen. Also wir haben schon das Gefühl, dass wir da einfach wirklich eine Lücke schließen. Denn in Deutschland gab es bislang einfach keine Organisationen für strategisch geführte Prozesse. Wie habt ihr schon gesagt, so gelegentlich wurden mal spontan Verfassungsklagen organisiert, aber das hat bislang einfach niemand konsequent gemacht. Wir wollen uns aber auch nicht nur um Verfassungsklagen kümmern. Also schon Anfang Dezember wird ein Programm der GFF vorgestellt, wo es mit Informationsfreiheit geht. Da geht es dann auch um Klagen vor anderen Gerichten. Wie gesagt, kann ich jetzt noch nicht in Detail sagen, wird am 2. Dezember sehr wahrscheinlich öffentlich vorgestellt. Also es geht nicht nur um Verfassungsklagen. Also viele werden zwar Verfassungsklagen sein, aber wir werden auch andere Gerichte im Sinne der Freiheit anrufen.
Ganz Deutschland ist beschäftigt von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte. Wie kann man euch denn noch was Gutes tun jetzt zum Jahresende? Oder vielleicht, falls ich mit meiner Firma irgendwie noch ein bisschen Geld raus trage, bevor es das interessant kriegt?
Man kann sich zunächst mal unsere Homepage angucken auf freiheitsrechte.org und sich noch ein bisschen genauer informieren, was wir tun. Und dort gibt es auch natürlich einen Spendenbutton und noch schöner einen Mitmachen-Button, wo man uns als Fördermitglied beitreten kann. Das mit den Fördermitgliedschaften ist deswegen so großartig, weil man sich dann darauf verlassen kann, dass eben einmal im Jahr oder monatlich ein bestimmter Beitrag kommt. Und das erlaubt es uns dann zum Beispiel, ein Büro anzumieten oder auch Leute einzustellen. Also wir freuen uns natürlich auch über Spenden, aber Fördermitgliedschaften haben den großen Vorteil, dass sie eine bessere Planungsgrundlage uns geben. Und insofern freuen wir uns sehr über jede Unterstützung.
Na, ich bin sehr gespannt, was da aber noch rumkommt. Ulf Buermeyer war das von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte. Vielen Dank und viel Vergnügen. Halt's den Bein hoch, ich weiß nicht genau.
Ehrlich gesagt, sowas in der Richtung habe ich jetzt noch gar nicht gehört. So im Kollegenkreise. Vielleicht sagt man, was sagt man denn da? Naja, ich mache das ja auch nicht beruflich. Das ist ja, das ist ja mein juristisches Hobby, wenn ihr so wollt. Und ich glaube, viel Spaß und viel Erfolg wäre passend.
Na dann, viel Spaß und viel Erfolg.
Vielen Dank, euch eine gute Sendung.
So, hätten wir das also geklärt. Was ich mich übrigens die ganze Zeit noch gefragt habe, ist, man muss jetzt sagen, also diese Auseinandersetzung mit Politik und Freiheitsrechten im Netz, das geht ja seit Jahren, Jahrzehnten fast schon. Das muss jetzt sozusagen professionalisiert werden, dass das vor das oberste Gericht in Deutschland kommt. Fühlt man sich da, und ich muss jetzt mal verallgemeinern, als Hackerin oder Hacker sich sozusagen so ein bisschen wie die Niederlage, weil das jetzt sozusagen passieren muss, man nicht geschafft hat, irgendwie das vorher zu diktieren, das Thema. Also nicht vorher im Staat zu verankern, dass dieses Netz und sozusagen unsere Kommunikationsfreiheiten besser geschützt sind? Auf der einen Seite ja, auf der anderen Seite muss ich ja sagen, die Idee, die Ulf da mit seinen Kollegen und Kollegin hatte, ist ja an sich ein Hack. Und zwar ein ziemlich genialer, weil er nutzt die rechtlichen Möglichkeiten aus und installiert quasi mit dieser Gesellschaft etwas, was quasi das, also diese Versicherungsidee finde ich total gut, als Bild. Also ich kann, wenn ich, also was habe ich denn als, ich sag mal, ein einstens ein normaler Bürger, für eine Möglichkeit im parlamentarischen Betrieb einzugreifen, abgesehen von Wahlen? Es ist ja, wenn ich jetzt keine Zeit habe, mich aktiv zu beteiligen oder mich rausreden, mich aktiv beteiligen zu können, wie auch immer, dann ist das, dann davon abgesehen bin ich ja relativ beschränkt. Aber indem ich mich in jetzt in solchen Organisationen einbringe und sei es nur mit mit Geld, habe ich eben die Möglichkeit, Teil eines Korrektivs zu sein. Und also ich fand, als ich zum ersten Mal von der Idee gehört habe, fand ich das sehr, sehr großartig. Also auch im Sinne von, also das war tatsächlich ein Gedanke, was ein geiler Hack.
Ich denke auch, dass das einfach etwas ist. Also diese ganze Politik, Netzpolitik, ist zwar extrem relevant für uns, aber etwas, womit sich viele von uns eigentlich gar nicht so richtig gerne beschäftigen. Also wir würden halt gerne die ideale Welt haben, in denen wir irgendwie das alles in Ruhe machen können und irgendwie die Gesetze alle so sind, wie wir uns das vorstellen. Aber viele beschäftigen sich mit dem Thema und setzen sich dafür ein, eigentlich weil es nur uns gab, die damit genug dafür genug Verständnis hatten und sie sich dafür eingesetzt haben. Und leider sind wir da eben nicht so weit gekommen, wie wir wünschen. Natürlich wäre es schön, wenn wir da unsere Ziele erreicht hätten, aber jetzt eben professionelle Unterstützung aus dem Bereich zu bekommen, gibt uns auch so ein bisschen ein Stück Freiheit zurück, uns wieder auch mehr um andere Dinge zu kümmern und die Dinge, die uns auch wichtig sind. Natürlich werden wir diesen Kampf nicht aufgehen. Aber wie gesagt, wir sind eben nicht mehr, sozusagen, also wir haben einfach Unterstützung an unserer Seite, die sich auch mit dem Thema natürlich einfach besser auskennt als wir.
Darf ich versuchen ein Bild zu bemühen?
Gerne.
Man sitzt in einem Hobbykeller und will eigentlich eine Figur schnitzen, aber der Keller steht unter Wasser. Deswegen begibt man sich ständig an das Rohr, um das zuzuhalten. Aber jetzt kommen die Klempner, die wirklich eine von der Sache haben, man kann die Figur schnitzen gehen?
Genau, in die Richtung.
Okay, verstehe. Aufgabenteilung sozusagen. Nicht schlecht. Wollt ihr auch noch oder?
Ja, prinzipiell ist genau das halt der Punkt. Also ich meine, wir haben einen professionellen Politikbetrieb und da kann man auch halt eben sagen, es ist sehr gut, dass wir dann auch ein professionelles Gegenstück dann in Form eben der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte haben.
Okay, ich bin sehr gespannt. Kommen wir jetzt zum zweiten Thema. Es geht heute Schlag auf Schlag. Also für ein Chaosradio ist sozusagen, also das wäre jetzt nach 20 Minuten schon Zeit. Das ist schon krass. Holt euch mal ein paar alte Folgen an. Und zwar, es klang gerade schon an, es geht um BND sozusagen, um Geheimdienste. Und um Geheimdienste geht es darum, wieder auch beim NSA Untersuchungsausschuss, die ja seit Snowden das ganze Zeug online gebracht hat oder gelegt hat, sich damit beschäftigen, wie ist denn das eigentlich sozusagen so in Deutschland? Was wird denn da von dem, was Snowden da so belegt hat, alles bei uns umgesetzt? Wie hängt denn der BND dann immer drin? Und wenn man das alles so hört und verfolgt hat, dann fragt man sich ja auch, könnte man nicht eigentlich den Snowden selbst mal fragen? Es ist nicht passiert aus verschiedenen Gründen. Und jetzt gab es eine Gerichtsentscheidung, die irgendwas damit zu tun hat, dass man Snowden jetzt doch hierher einladen und fragen kann, was das genau bedeutet und was das überhaupt ist. Er wird uns jetzt Anne Roth erklären, war auch schon häufiger im Chaosradio zu Gast zum Thema NSA Untersuchungsausschuss und ist jetzt auch bei uns per Skype. Hallo und guten Abend. So, also die Schlagzeile ist, der BGH erlaubt der Opposition im NSA Untersuchungsausschuss Snowden einzuladen. Was genau ist da passiert?
Das Problem, nein, was ist passiert? Also der BGH hat einen Beschluss gefasst, nachdem die Opposition, also Grüne und Linke, im Sommer einen Antrag an den BGH gerichtet haben und versucht haben zu erreichen, dass ein Antrag überhaupt abgestimmt wird. Und das ist so kompliziert, dass das in keine Schlagzeile passt und auch in vielen Artikeln so ein bisschen doll vereinfacht war. Und letztlich denke ich mir dann aber auch, vielleicht reicht das auch aus, vielleicht muss man es nicht in allen seinen komplizierten juristischen Facetten beschreiben.
Okay, da darf ich mich dann noch mal an der Vereinfachung versuchen. Ist es quasi so, dass der Untersuchungsausschuss ist ja im Prinzip danach ausgerichtet, wie groß die Parteien auch im Parlament sind. Und Opposition heißt ja, das sind die kleineren und dass es darum geht, dass die, die eigentlich nicht die Mehrheit haben, trotzdem was durchsetzen können sozusagen gegen den Willen der Mehrheit. Ist das der Punkt, um den es ging?
Darum geht es auch. Es geht um Minderungenrechte und die sind eben festgeschrieben im Untersuchungsausschussgesetz unter anderem und heißen da eben, dass die Minderheit von 25 Prozent eben auch bestimmte Sachen machen darf. Die darf nicht alles alleine bestimmen, aber sie hat schon bestimmte Rechte, genauso wie die Minderheit im Parlament ja auch ein Untersuchungsausschuss überhaupt einsetzen kann. Und wenn sie ihn einsetzen kann, dann muss sie natürlich auch bestimmte Möglichkeiten haben, da drinnen was zu machen. In dieser speziellen Situation ist das noch mehr so, weil der gesamte Ausschuss mit den Stimmen der Mehrheit beschlossen hat, dass Snowden Zeuge sein soll und danach dann aber immer verhindert hat, dass er tatsächlich eingeladen wird. Wie das? Ja, Beweisanträge kann die Opposition alleine stellen, also sagen wir wollen bestimmte Materialien zu bestimmten Themen von der Regierung haben oder eben auch Zeugen benennen beispielsweise oder Sachverständige, aber sogenannte Verfahrensanträge, also nämlich wann das dann stattfindet, das kann die Minderheit nicht alleine und da hat die Mehrheit bisher das immer verschoben und argumentiert, dass sowieso erstmal die Bundesregierung sich äußern müsste, ob sie ihm denn freies Geleit gibt und die Bundesregierung hat ihrerseits dann auch schön verzögert und mal gesagt naja wir wissen ja gar nicht was ihm vorgeworfen wird und wenn dann beispielsweise auch Sachverständige aus den USA fassungslos im Ausschuss saßen und auf diese Frage sagten naja bitte das weiß ja jeder steht ja auch im Internet behauptet die Bundesregierung trotzdem sie weiß es nicht und jetzt kürzlich hat sie nachdem sie eine eigene Arbeitsgruppe im Justizministerium eingesetzt hat die heraus also erstmal darüber nachdenken sollte welche Fragen man geschickterweise an die. Also um den es geht, den der BGH beschlossen hat, geht es nicht darum, dass die Bundesregierung verpflichtet worden wäre oder dass der BGH beschlossen hat, dass Snowden jetzt sofort nach Berlin fliegt, sondern lediglich um den ganz kleinen Baustein, der aber entscheidend ist in dem Fall, dass der BGH gesagt hat, der die Mehrheit im Ausschuss darf nicht mehr verhindern, dass die Minderheit im Ausschuss mit den Antrag stellt und der dann auch beschlossen wird, dass die Bundesregierung jetzt Und was sie jetzt endlich mal sagen soll, was Sache ist. Was die wichtigste Voraussetzung ist, um ihn dann laden zu können.
Aber das klingt jetzt eigentlich fast zu gut, um wahr zu sein. Aber du sagtest auch kleiner Baustein. Ich wollte gerade sagen, es gibt jetzt diesen kleinen Baustein, dass die Opposition sozusagen den Antrag dann stellen darf. Und was das Ergebnis sozusagen ist, dass das jetzt so sein kann, das kennen wir nach den Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr. Sprechen dann gleich noch mal mit Anne Roth jetzt erst mal wie gesagt Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr und danach geht es hier weiter im Chaosradio im Blue Moon.
Nur noch zwei Nächte, dann kommt die eine Nacht. Elf überraschend talentierte Talente, ein überraschender Überraschungsgast und ein Admiralspalast, der Überraschung schon wieder mal komplett ausverkauft ist. Aber Fritz wäre nicht Fritz Fritz nicht noch eine Überraschung für euch parat hätte.
Fritz hat sie für euch.
Die letzten Tickets für die Fritz-Nacht der Talente Samstagabend im Admiralspalast direkt an der Friedrichstraße mit jeder Menge guter Musik und guter Comedy, den Fritz-Moderatoren Katrin Thüring und Chris Guese und vielleicht auch mit euch.
Einfach gut Fritz hören und klicken. fritz.de slash Talente.
Und mit ein bisschen Glück seid ihr noch mit dabei.
Die Fritz-Nacht der Talente.
Natürlich nur bei, mit, von und überhaupt Fritz.
Mit Timo Maschewski.
Der Pilotenstreik bei der Lufthansa wird noch einmal verlängert. Von der Gewerkschaft Cockpit hieß es am Abend, auch am Samstag werde gestreikt, dann sollen wieder überwiegend Langstreckenflüge betroffen sein. Morgen am Freitag trifft es dagegen vor allem die Kurz- und Mittelstrecke. Cockpit fordert für die Piloten rückwirkend mehr Geld. Die Lufthansa verlangt von der Gewerkschaft, dass sie einer Schlichtung zusteppt. Verbeamtete Lehrer müssen in Berlin auch in den Ferien zur Schule. Das hat das Verwaltungsgericht entschieden und damit eine gesetzliche Neuregelung aus dem letzten Jahr für rechtens erklärt. Seit der Neuregelung gelten für Lehrer am Ende der Sommerferien drei Vorbereitungstage, vorher war es nur einer. Lehrer haben 30 Urlaubstage im Jahr. Das Gericht hat jetzt entschieden, dass sie mit den 13 Wochen Ferien abgegolten sind. Der Wechsel des bisherigen EU- Parlamentspräsidenten Schulz in die Bundespolitik ist eine gute Nachricht für Deutschland. So sieht es zumindest die SPD. Von dort heißt es, Schulz sei ein Gewinn für den Bundestag. Kritik an seine Entscheidung kommt dagegen von der EU. Kommissionschef Juncker sagte, man hätte Schulz weiter bei der EU gebraucht. Schulz hatte heute angekündigt, dass er seinen Posten im EU-Parlament aufgeben will. Es wird darüber spekuliert, dass er möglicherweise neuer Außenminister oder SPD-Kanzlerkandidat werden könnte. Rund um die israelische Küstenstadt Haifa wüten heftige Buschbrände. Die Behörden haben dort rund 60.000 Menschen aus der Stadt in Sicherheit gebracht. Mithilfe der Armee versucht die Feuerwehr, die Brände unter Kontrolle zu kriegen. Russland, die Türkei, Griechenland und andere Länder haben Israel Hilfe angeboten. Die Polizei prübt gerade, ob jemand die Brände absichtlich gelegt hat. Ministerpräsident Netanyahu hat angekündigt, jede Brandstiftung als Terrorakt zu verfolgen. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Berlin-Pankow hat 1°C und Steglitz 3°C. In Bad Freienwalde sind es 0°C. Netzeband meldet 1°C, Ludwigsfelder hat 2°C und Cottbus noch 4°C. Die Nacht über ist der Himmel oft klar hier und da kann es aber sehr neblig sein. Dafür wird es auch nicht mehr viel kälter als jetzt. Die Tiefstwerte liegen um minus 2°C. Auch den Tag über hält sich oft Nebel oder Hochnebel am Himmel. Im Süden kann sich auch noch mal länger die Sonne zeigen. Mehr als 4°C sind wahrscheinlich aber nicht drin. Auch am Samstag soll es noch ziemlich trübe sein. Am Sonntag dann aber schöner. Vorsicht auf der A24 Hamburg-Berlin. Zwischen Herzsprung und Neuropin stehen Leute auf der Autobahn. Die A113, der Zubringer Schönefeld Richtung Dresden, ist zwischen Adlershof und Schönefeld Nord wegen Bauarbeiten gesperrt. Und schon mal Vormerken, bei der U-Bahn-Linie U7 beginnt morgen früh die letzte Bauphase. Bis Sonntagbetriebsschluss ist dann der Zugverkehr zwischen Drittsüt und Rudow unterbrochen. Da gibt es dann aber Ersatzverkehr mit Bussen. Dort bloß geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und wenn ihr diesen Sound mögt......oder diesen Sound......dann hört doch mal den Fritz Soundgarden mit Christoph Schraas.
Am Montagabend ab 20 Uhr und im Radio. Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de.
Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon. Herzlich willkommen zurück. Wir sprechen heute mit den Vertretern vom Chaos Computer Club, die aus Danimo, Carina, Matthias und Sokrates bestehen. Hallo. Hallo. Hallo. Über viele verschiedene Themen. Wir hatten jetzt auch gerade noch einen zugeschalteten Gast, nämlich Ulf Buermeyer, der uns darüber aufgeklärt hat, was die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte ist, nämlich so eine Art Verfassungsklagerät für das Parlament, könnte man sagen, oder gegen das Parlament. Man weiß es nicht so genau. Und sprechen jetzt gerade mit Anne Roth darüber, ob wir vielleicht demnächst Herrn Edward Snowden vom NSA Untersuchungsausschuss begrüßen dürfen. Willkommen zurück. Hallo. Wir hatten jetzt gerade am Anfang geklärt, dass BGH hat jetzt der Opposition im Untersuchungsausschuss erlaubt, den Antrag alleine durchdrücken zu können, Herrn Snowden einzuladen. Was passiert jetzt?
Na, heute ist schon wieder was passiert, weil heute war ja wieder Untersuchungsausschuss und es war auch wieder eine sogenannte Beratungssitzung. Das ist der nichtöffentliche Teil, wo eben über so eine Sachen diskutiert wird und auch abgestimmt wird, welche sind die Zeugen, was passiert da so? Also alles das, was sozusagen vor und nach den Zeugenanhörungen passiert. Und da hat dann die Opposition eben tatsächlich den Antrag auch nochmal gestellt und gesagt so, den wir genau denselben Antrag, so wie es auch im BGH-Beschluss steht, den geben wir jetzt nochmal zur Abstimmung. Stellen wir zur Abstimmung und dann meldete sich ein Vertreter der Koalition und hat, ich überlege jetzt gerade, ob ich den namentlich nenne oder nicht, ist ja eine nichtöffentliche Sitzung. Ich glaube, es ist irgendwie verschiedentlich, kurz danach über Sozialdemokratie sehr hässlich getwittert worden. Also jedenfalls ein Vertreter der Koalition hat sich dann gemeldet und hat die Vertragung beantragt. Na ja, das ist genau das, was der BGH gesagt hat, was sie nicht dürfen. Nämlich da in dem BGH-Geschoss steht ja, es muss unverzüglich abgestimmt werden. Da gibt es jetzt keine aufschiebende Wirkung mehr und nichts. Und die Koalition sagt ja, das interessiert uns nicht.
Also die vertagen sozusagen, dass sie überhaupt darüber sprecht.
Oder dass das darüber eingeladen wird.
Also Opposition beantragt, wir wollen jetzt irgendwie noch mal abstimmen lassen. Diesmal dürft ihr, also Klammer auf wurde nicht dazu gesagt, diesmal dürft ihr das nicht abnehmen, hat der BGH gesagt. Und dann sagt die Koalition, ja, nö, machen wir aber nicht viel vertagen. Das ist einfach, das ist sehr beliebt. Das haben die schon zigmal gemacht. Es geht halt darum, das zu verzögern. Die wollen natürlich nicht, dass Snowden herkommt. Die wollen vor allen Dingen die Bundesregierung auch nicht in diese Bredouille bringen, entscheiden zu müssen, ob sie sich mit der US-Regierung, ja, versauen. Ist jetzt so die Interpretation der Bundesregierung als Argument. Da ging es auch schon bei der Verfassungsgerichtsentscheidung eine Woche vorher darum, dass die Beziehungen zu den USA vollständig kaputt gehen würden und massiv leiden würden, wenn so was passiert. Was ich im Übrigen für relativ eine unbewiesene Behauptung halte, weil die USA zum Beispiel...
Das ist ja schon jetzt der nächste Schritt. Jetzt nochmal zurück, bitte. Also die haben jetzt gesagt, so ihr habt gesagt, wir wollen abstimmen. Die haben die gesagt, so ne, ne, ne, ne, wir stimmen heute nicht ab. Das machen wir später irgendwann. Das hat ja aber das BGH so gesagt, eigentlich verboten. Müssen die jetzt irgendwie Strafe zahlen oder was passiert da jetzt?
Na, das ist so eine Situation, wo du denkst irgendwie, das ist jetzt halt so richtig offen gegen Gesetz verstoßen. Also aktiv illegal sich betätigt haben die Bundestagsabgeordneten der Koalition. Und das ist ihnen aber offensichtlich wurscht. Also sie haben da sehr zufrieden zurückgelehnt in ihre Sessel gesessen und eben ihre Mehrheit ausgenutzt. Und in dem Moment konnten wir da gar nicht dafür viel machen. Da könnte man jetzt wieder zum Gericht gehen und eine Beschwerde einlegen und so weiter. Das werden wir uns jetzt überlegen, was wir tun. Und die Frage ist natürlich auch, wann die dann zulassen, dass abgestimmt wird, ob sie das überhaupt nicht machen oder ob sie es dann vielleicht in der nächsten Sitzungswoche machen. Das wissen wir nicht. Es gab auch schon welche, die zitiert wurden, gesagt haben, sie werden jetzt erst mal Beschwerde gegen den Beschluss einlegen. Ist es aber auch so. Und dann hast du halt jede Menge Juristen mit dicken Schinken unter am Arm, die aufeinander losgehen. Das welche sagen, ja, aber diese Beschwerde, die hat gar keine aufschiebende Wirkung. Steht in Paragraph so und so. Das Gesetz ist XYZ. Das heißt, es muss trotzdem abgestimmt werden. Aber wenn die Mehrheit im Ausschuss sich da einfach nicht umschert, dann können sie natürlich letzten Endes machen, was sie wollen. Und das finde ich illustriert ganz schön, was da in dieser großen Koalition gerade passiert. Also die Gesetze sind schön und gut, wenn es ihnen in den Kram passt. Aber wenn nicht, dann nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das jetzt beantworten kannst, aber es gibt ja, so vor Gericht ist ja, man kann eine Revision einlegen, aber es gibt ja irgendwann mal auch einen Punkt, wo ein Gericht sagt, okay, das ist die Entscheidung und die ist auch nicht mehr anfechtbar. Wenn das BGH das sagt, können sich dann sozusagen die Leute in dem Untersuchungsausschuss dann immer noch sozusagen sagen, Mühe machen wir trotzdem nicht und dann passiert nichts. Also gibt es da nicht eine Strafe?
Ne, eine Strafe gibt es auf jeden Fall nicht. Also es hat schon mal auch einen BND Untersuchungsausschuss gegeben, wo es eine sehr ähnliche Situation gab, wo die Opposition also entsprechend sich verhalten hat, nicht in allen Facetten gleich, aber da hat die Koalition geschafft, das so lange rauszuzögern, bis dann der entsprechende Beschluss des damals Verfassungsgerichtes, um dass es dagegen genau drei Tage nach Ende des Untersuchungsausschusses fiel und dann nützt es halt nichts mehr, weil dann ist der Untersuchungsausschuss vorbei und es ist, glaube ich, nicht schwer vorhersehbar, dass die Koalition hier genau dasselbe vorhat.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das so geil fürs Demokratieverständnis ist, was da gerade passiert.
Ich glaube, das ist ganz schlecht fürs Demokratieverständnis. Was zum Vorteil der Koalition ist, ist, dass das so kompliziert ist, dass es kaum wer versteht. Ja, das ist ein Vorteil, weil man kann schlecht darüber berichten. Es ist schlecht, einfach Leuten zu erklären, was hier die Schweinerei ist. Aber genau mit dieser Situation haben wir jetzt seit zweieinhalb Jahren zu kämpfen.
Wie frustrierend. Chaosradio ist immer frustrierend. Ja, aber es gibt schon sozusagen so, oh Gott, irgendwie mein Handy ist nicht sicher und ich muss halt jederzeit am Rechen gehackt werden. Und es gibt, okay, das Organ, was eigentlich dafür zuständig ist, Demokratie zu machen, funktioniert nicht so richtig. Das ist schon schwierig, schwieriger als andere Sachen.
Aber ich finde es, wenn ich das vielleicht noch dazu sagen darf, gerade an dieser Stelle, also auch wirklich eine irre Schweinerei, weil Snowden einfach wirklich so viel zu sagen hätte darüber, wie das mit der Überwachung funktioniert. Wir haben direkt nachdem das dann heute passiert ist, wieder mehrere Zeugen vom BND da gehabt. Die großen Erinnerungslücken hatten überhaupt nie irgendwie einen Selektor gesehen, haben sich das alles nicht richtig erklären konnten. Also Standardprogramm BND, die wissen nichts, die erinnern sich an nichts, die haben nie jemandem irgendwas davon erzählt, was sie da gesehen haben und so weiter. Und wenn man sich vorstellt, da würde jetzt Snowden sitzen, ja, und würde nicht permanent zur Bundesregierung schielen, ob er jetzt noch einen Ton sagen darf, ja oder nein, sondern der würde einfach mal erzählen, was er darüber weiß. Dann hätten wir alle echt viel davon. Und genau das versucht diese Koalition, nach Kräften zu verhindern. Das finde ich auch vor allen Dingen deswegen unheimlich unerträglich, weil dieselben Vertreter dieser Koalition ja bei jeder Gelegenheit, in jedes Mikro und bei jeder Filmvorführung von Citizen 4 oder von Snowden oder so glücklich dabei sind und sich als die großen Aufklärer präsentieren, die auch wirklich interessiert sind an all diesen Sachen und Snowden ganz super finden und hinter verschlossener Tür machen sie dann eben genau das Gegenteil.
Sokrates, hat er eine Frage?
Nein, eine Frage nicht, sondern ich wollte da reinschmeißen, dass es eigentlich wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut ist, dass Snowden nicht kommt, weil ich denke nicht, dass die deutsche Regierung in der Lage ist, Snowden hier wirklich zu schützen.
Na, das wäre meine nächste Frage, wenn man davon ausgeht, okay, das geht jetzt vielleicht doch durch und der Untersuchungsausschuss besinnt sich eines Besseren und dann wird Snowden eingeladen. Würdet ihr überhaupt kommen?
Das muss natürlich Snowden entscheiden. Sein Anwalt Wolfgang Kaleck hat sich jetzt in dieser Sache natürlich auch schon geäußert und ganz klar erst mal, er will gerne aussagen, er wird nicht per Videoschalter aussagen, sondern wenn dann vor dem Ausschuss in Berlin und ob er dann letztlich kommt, das weiß nur er selber. Und was für ihn langfristig problematischer ist, das weiß wahrscheinlich von uns hier gerade niemand. Ich denke, wir müssen versuchen, die Gelegenheit zu schaffen. Ich glaube, dass die USA Deutschland nicht so doll unter Druck setzen, wie die deutsche Regierung uns das gerne weiß, machen will, weil das natürlich für sie auch viel bequemer ist. Ich denke, man müsste es auf den Versuch ankommen lassen. Und ich denke, so schwächlich sind die deutschen Sicherheitsbehörden vielleicht doch nicht, weiß man nicht. Aber ich denke, da gäbe es Möglichkeiten.
Du gehst sozusagen davon aus, dass wenn die Regierung das will, dann könnte man Snowden nach Deutschland kommen lassen, ohne dass er in Gefahr läuft, in die USA ausgeliefert zu werden.
Ich meine, bitte schön, die deutsch-amerikanischen Beziehungen in Zeiten von Trump. Ich glaube, da ist ein bisschen Rückgrat dringend nötig.
Ja, ja, könnte man eigentlich auch so stehen lassen. Meine Güte. Ein bisschen frustrierend. Ich hoffe, ihr gebt nicht auf. Und vielleicht dürfen wir den Herrn Snowden ja doch noch irgendwie in Berlin begrüßen. Schöner Herr, wer ist auf jeden Fall? Anne Roth war das?
Wir geben natürlich nicht auf.
Sehr gut. Dann vielen Dank und viel Spaß noch. So, gut, jetzt haben wir also sagen irgendwie, ja, also jetzt hier sogar an die Anwesenden im Studio. Wie fühlt ihr euch damit? Ich finde es ein bisschen bedenklich.
Ich würde sagen, also wenn Snowden hier herkommt, wäre es ein wahnsinnig guter Akt der Aufklärung. Aber die Amerikaner, wir dürfen das nicht vergessen, die haben hier wahnsinnige viele Militärbasen. Die werden einfach ein Zielteam los schicken und den einfach wegkaschen. Da gehe ich ganz stark von aus.
Entschuldigung, das ist doch aber Quatsch.
Nein, das ist nicht.
Ich gehe da ganz stark von aus.
Mit Verlaub, das finde ich Quatsch und ich finde auch gefährlich, so was zu sagen. Weil das würde bedeuten, dass sozusagen wirklich, also was wir im Untersuchungsausschuss sehen, das ist sozusagen Politik und das ist auch schon sehr bedenklich, dass das sozusagen, dass dann der Gerichtshintergrund ignoriert wird. Aber hier in die Welt zu setzen, es gibt überhaupt gar keine Kontrolle mehr und die schicken einfach einen James Bond-Trupp los und schnappen den weg, das halte ich, mit Verlaub, für gefährlich, so was zu sagen.
Das ist nicht von wegen keine Kontrolle mehr, sondern ich denke, dass in dem Fall eventuell sogar Absprachen möglich wären oder irgendwie andere Sachen passieren, weil wir haben wahnsinnig viele Amerikaner hier.
Das verstehe ich nicht ganz.
Wir haben hier ganz viele Militärbasen, die sind hier ganz stark integriert. Ich gehe davon aus, dass das ein ganz schwieriger Akt wäre.
Naja, aber der Punkt ist doch sozusagen, der würde doch nur dann kommen, wenn zugesichert wird, der wird nicht ausgeliefert.
Dann musst du aber einen Riesenakt fahren, um ihn überhaupt sicher zu halten hier.
Natürlich. Ja sicher.
Aber das ist halt der Deal. Also das wäre sowieso der Deal. Und das da stimme ich Markus schon zu. Das muss sich, oder auch Anna hat das, glaube ich, gesagt, das ist was, was der deutsche Staat sich leisten muss, anstatt sich mit sowas wie, ach, wir wissen gar nicht, ob das jetzt so geht, rauszureden. Weil es natürlich auch opportun, sowas erst mal da hinzustellen.
Und ich denke auch, wenn Snowden eine ganz, ganz besondere Person ist, so gibt es immer wieder umstrittene Personen, die nach Deutschland einreisen und die jetzt auch nicht sofort irgendwie ein Attentat passiert oder irgendwas in der Art. Also ich denke auch, dass es, das ist machbar. Er wird sich halt vielleicht nicht so komplett frei irgendwie durch Berlin spazieren. Aber es wäre natürlich wünschenswert, wäre ein Traum. Aber ich denke, das ist schaffbar und das ist nichts, was uns abschrecken sollte, Snowden einzuladen und aus Snowden ermutigen herzukommen und hier auszusagen. Denn ich denke, das ist ganz wichtig, dass wir das aufklären. Es ist ganz wichtig, dass er zu Wort kommt. Und es ist eben ganz wichtig, dass wir uns hier nicht irgendwelchen politischen Machtspielchen geschlagen geben und sagen, wir können uns da nicht durchsetzen, sondern dass wir da einfach zeigen, wir sind dafür, das Ganze unterstützen, hoffen, dass dieses Vorhaben, was da ist, also der Ausschuss, zu dem Ziel kommt, was wir uns wünschen, nämlich eine wirklich echte, umfassende Aufklärung und ja.
Vielleicht habe ich das falsch ausgedrückt. Mir bin mir nur bewusst, was das für ein Riesenaufwand ist.
Das ist korrekt, also sagen.
Hast du mal mitbekommen, wie der Aufwand war, wenn Obama in die Stadt kommt oder so? Also seriously. Das ist machbar.
Nein, das ist aber positiv. Das ist von allen Seiten positiv empfunden, wenn Obama hierherkommt, außer von der Bevölkerung. Nur es gibt.
Ja, ja, also aber wie gesagt, so irgendwie Elbphilharmonie, Stuttgart 21, BeR, Obama Besuch. Wir kriegen auf jeden Fall bezahlt, dass das nun sicher ist, dass bezahlt, bezahlt. Ja, aber darum geht's ja. Es ist halt Aufwand und der Aufwand muss geleistet werden. Und der ist sozusagen, der ist möglich. Und das die viel wichtigere Diskussion ist eigentlich eine innenpolitische, weil das hast du auch gerade angesprochen. Letztendlich muss sich die Regierungskoalition halt im Klaren sein, was sie, was sie möchte. Möchte sie weiter wuseln und dabei riskieren, den politischen Betrieb und seinen Ansehen weiter zu schädigen? Oder möchte sie gerade im Hinblick auf die Wahlen sagen, wir klären das lieber auf und stellen fest, dass was schiefgelaufen ist und klären das halt anstatt irgendwelchen Kräften, die halt von dem Defekt des Regierungsbetriebes profitieren würden. Das natürlich nicht besser machen würden, aber auf jeden Fall davon propagandistisch. Das ist halt, also ich glaube, man muss sich da im politischen Berlin einfach im Klaren sein, dass das echt das deutlich schlimmere Übel ist, weiter rumzuwieseln. Was man glaube ich derzeit absolut nicht so sieht. In der Tat, ich bin sehr gespannt, was da mal rumkommt.
Und vor allem, da Herr Snowden ja auch nicht vollkommen risikoervers ist, sind die Chancen vielleicht tatsächlich gar nicht so schlecht, dass er vorbeikommt.
Na, wir werden mal sehen. Wir werden jetzt sagen, bevor wir das nächste Thema angehen, es geht an der Schlagaufschlag, Freunde und Freundinnen, Schlagaufschlag, eine kleine Musik. Und zwar kommt die ganze Musik, die wir heute im Chaosradio spielen, von Breakbeat, Heartbeat, einer You Were My Friend EP und der erste Titel davon heißt auch genauso You Were My Friend. Danach geht's hier im Chaosradio weiter mit Weihnachtsgeschenken. You Were My Friend von Breakbeat Heartbeat von der You Were My Friend EP. Creative Commons Musik kann man sich also einfach so runterladen, kostenlos oder wenn man Geld geben will, kann man das auch drauf werfen. Und den Link gibt es in den Show notes zur Sendung. Und die wiederum, die wiederum sind, wo genau eigentlich? Auf chaosradio.ccc.de gibt es dann zur entsprechenden Sendung den Link. Das müssen wir noch machen. Das gibt es dann im Laufe des nächsten Tages, denke ich. Sehr gut, so machen wir das. So wir sprechen heute im Chaosradio über verschiedene Themen. Und als wir so am Anfang beratschliffen haben, ja, worüber können wir sprechen? Viel auch. Und das habe ich tatsächlich noch nie im Chaosradio gehört. Und ich habe ja schon sehr viel gehört, das Thema Weihnachtsgeschenke. Entschuldigung, worum geht es?
Also mein Anliegen war es sozusagen, so ein bisschen einen Aufruf zu machen. Wir sind ja nicht die Einzigen, die irgendwie sagen, ja, überlegt euch, was ihr zu Weihnachten schenkt. Also es gibt ja immer diesen Aufruf, schenkt keine Haustiere. Genauso möchte ich in die Richtung gehen, natürlich nicht ganz so dramatisch. Nämlich schenkt keine Technik, die eure Liebsten ausspioniert. Also gerade Technik ist etwas, was zu Weihnachten ja unheimlich gerne verschenkt wird, irgendwelche Spielereien. Und ganz beliebt sind da auch zum Beispiel aktuell diese Fitnessarmbänder. Die können irgendwie Notifications von den Telefonen und so darstellen, vibrieren dann am Handgelenk und dies und jenes. Zählen die Schritte. So gerade mit dem Neujahrsvorsatz, den viele sich ja setzen, irgendwie gesünder und fitter zu leben, ist das was, was für viele denke ich interessant ist. Aber die Dinger spionieren einen ja aus. Also es wird ja festgehalten, wie viel man sich bewegt, wann man sich bewegt, wo man ist. Und das Ganze wird bei den meisten dieser Geräten eben nicht irgendwie auf dem Handy nur gespeichert, was ja okay wäre, sondern das wird natürlich auf die Server der Hersteller hochgeladen. Das heißt, diese ganzen Daten und so werden da hochgestellt. Man weiß nicht, was damit passiert.
Man weiß nicht, wie viele Sicherheitsschwankungen es zwischendurch gibt.
Genau, also man weiß erst mal nicht, ob vielleicht irgendwo Sicherheitslücken entstehen, wodurch andere weitere Daten aufgegriffen werden. Aber man weiß auch bei manchen dieser chinesischen Hersteller oder so auch gar nicht, ob diese App nicht von vornherein einfach noch direkt mal mittrackt, mit wem ich telefoniere, wann ich telefoniere, was Inhalte von meinen SMS'n etc. etc.
Ich muss dich aber fragen, also gilt das generell die ganze Gerätekategorie oder heißt das, also wenn ihr so ein Ding holt, dann informiert euch bitte sehr sorgfältig darüber, wie das funktioniert.
Genau, also mein Wunsch geht eigentlich in die zweite Richtung, informiert euch genau, was machen die Geräte. Es geht auch jetzt nicht nur um Fitness-Tracker, es geht auch um irgendwelche Puppen, die mittlerweile im Internet sind, also eigentlich so alles, was in diese Richtung Internet of Sinks geht. Diese ganzen Gerätschaften, die Daten sammeln und sie ins Internet stellen, braucht man das wirklich? Ist das ein Vorteil? Was für Daten werden erhoben? Werden die wirklich hochgeladen zum Hersteller? Es gibt auch Produkte, die das Ganze lokal behalten oder eben mit alternativen Apps betrieben werden können bei solchen Geräten, damit das Ganze eben nicht irgendwo hingeht, sondern bei einem Lokal bleibt. Und ja, einfach schaut genau, was die Sachen machen, damit ihr euren Liebsten, den ihr irgendwas Gutes ja tun wollt, nicht eine Datenkrake ins Haus setzt, sondern eben etwas auswählt, was sie nicht ausspioniert und anfällig macht, sondern ja sicher ist.
Schenkt keine Cloud?
So in die Richtung. So eine Ohncloud geht schon. Kleines nass mit Ohncloud drauf.
Da könnte ich wieder rumgeschehen. Das ist ja jetzt sozusagen, ich schenke nicht das und das, aber was schenkt man da, gibt es denn sozusagen, außer die Bücher? Ich wollte jetzt gerade sagen, außer Dinge, die halt sowieso komplett super analog sind. E-Books. Das stimmt ja schon wieder nicht, weil bei E-Books hat man auch wieder nicht Amazon, weil die gucken ja auch, was du so liest und das ist auch alles mit DRM behaftet.
Wobei, selbst ohne jetzt Werbung machen zu wollen, es möglich ist, zum Beispiel Kindle und auch ganz viele andere mit anderer Software zu benutzen, wo man eben nicht darauf angewiesen ist, das Ganze mit Amazon zu benutzen. Also genau solche Sachen, einfach sich mal damit zu beschäftigen, nicht nur, was gibt es, sondern was gibt es auch für Alternativen. Die Geräte sind ja teilweise gar nicht schlecht, sondern einfach, wie kann man es anders nutzen, also mit anderen Anwendungen. Und es ist auch, finde ich, eine super Gelegenheit, Leute umzustellen. Das heißt, viele sagen ja, wenn ich frage, warum benutzt du denn noch WhatsApp? Ja, weil da ist meine ganze Familie, da sind alle. Und was dann super Idee ist einfach, das muss jetzt nicht ein Weihnachtsgeschenk sein, das kann man schon zu Nikolaus machen, irgendwie so eine Kleinigkeit. Hey, hier ist eine Lizenz für Streamer, für Signal, also für einen sicheren Messenger, damit man mit diesen Leuten eben sicher kommunizieren kann. Und natürlich kosten diese Messenger etwas, weil na gut, man zahlt halt für den Messenger, statt sich selbst sozusagen als Produkt zu verkaufen. Naja, es gibt ja diesen schönen Produkt, wenn es nix kostet, bist du das Produkt. Und deswegen, also verschenkt da die Zugänge, das gibt es sogar als Möglichkeit, wirklich bei, ich glaube Streamer kann man das auch wirklich machen. Da muss man sozusagen gar nicht sagen, hier, ich geb ihr Geld, oder von mir, es schenkt auch eine Karte für einen Play Store mit irgendwie Guthaben drauf, dass die Leute ja dann eben mit euch sicher kommunizieren können.
Okay, also sozial, also die schöne Familientradition von sozialem Druck verbinden mit sinnvollen Technikern. Okay, interessante Idee. Sokrates, muss ich mal drüber nachdenken.
Ja, also, und wenn es dann wirklich low cost sein darf, dann kann man sich auch mal einen eigenen Java Server irgendwo hinstellen oder irgendeinen Fremden nutzen. Es gibt ja ganz viele auf, ne?
Also, ich weiß nicht, ob sie dann für die breite Masse einen eigenen Java Server hinstellen, das ist gar kein Evidenzgeschehen, aber wenn ihr die Herausforderung sucht, sehr gerne. Aber wo wir gerade bei den Messengern sind, das ist ja immer die Frage, was ist denn jetzt der sicherste Messenger? Und wenn man jetzt sagt, nutzt doch nicht WhatsApp, dann kann es dir eher passieren, dass du ihm ankommst und sagst, aber Amnesty International hat gesagt, WhatsApp ist der sicherste Messenger. Was?
Welchen Nicht-Techie haben die denn daran gelassen?
Naja, Amnesty International hat halt neulich so ein Ding rausgegeben, wo dann sozusagen das Ergebnis war, also WhatsApp zählt zu den sichersten Messengern, die es halt da draußen so gibt. Da haben dann andere sozusagen News-Siten überrichtet, gleich noch gemacht, ja Facebook-Messenger auch. Das hat Amnesty International nicht gesagt, aber das wurde sozusagen so berichtet, weil da Dinge durcheinander geworfen wurden. Und naja, also im Endeffekt hat Amnesty International gesagt, wir testen einfach nicht Signal oder Streamer, weil da gibt es zu wenig User. Da haben sie gesagt, wir testen nur die großen Messenger. Und deswegen erfüllen wir WhatsApp, weil da ist ja auch Verschlüsselung drin.
Ja, das ist korrekt, da ist auch Verschlüsselung drin.
Also willst du mir sagen, die Argumentation war, weil WhatsApp standardmäßig als als einer der wenigen großen, in Anführungszeichen, noch die beste Krypto hat. Ja, wurde es sozusagen empfohlen als das gut. Es gibt wirklich einen kurzen Amnesty International Artikel, wo das dringend steht. Dazu gibt es dann ein längeres PDF, das ist so 20 Seiten. Und da steht explizit drin, wir haben Signal nicht genommen, weil zu wenig User.
Das heißt, sie haben sozusagen den Einäugigen unter den Blinden gekürt. Ich glaube, das ist auch eine ganz passende Analogie, denn so ist es. Es gibt einfach auch Messager, die sehen können, aber die wurden dann nicht genommen, weil die nicht in der breiten Masse so bekannt sind. Das ist natürlich nicht gerade hilfreich, um zu sagen, vielleicht steigt ihr doch mal auf was anderes um. Nur wenn man das Beste von schlechten Möglichkeiten benutzt, heißt das einfach nicht, dass das eine gute Alternative ist.
Also der Punkt ist sozusagen, ich kann das ja nicht anders verstehen, dass man sagt, so Leute, ihr habt folgende Dinge auf eurem Telefon. Skype, Telegram, Signal, Fiber, was auch immer. Und wir sagen euch jetzt mal, welcher davon sozusagen der sicherste ist. Aber dann muss man doch am Ende sagen, okay, aber es gibt noch einen, der ist viel, viel besser. Und warum man das nicht macht? Also liebes Amnesty International, das kannst du bitte mal erklären. Fand ich sehr seltsam. Ich glaube, es ging auch darum, so ein bisschen das Ganze auf eine headlinefähige Nachricht runterzubrechen. Ja, nicht, dass ich das befürworten würde. Ich weiß auch nicht. Aber wenn man fragt, häufig auch Signal und Threema genannt werden. Ich weiß, und das muss an sehr schnell immer wieder gesagt werden, der Chaos Computer Club gibt keine Empfehlungen, ist kein TÜV für irgendwelche Sachen. Aber welches ist denn nun der sicherste Messenger und aus welchen Gründen? Also ein sicherer Messenger ist erst mal einer, und da hat Amnesty durchaus recht, der Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung macht. Und das hat aus diversen Gründen so ein paar Implikationen. Zum Beispiel stellt man dann fest, dass diese sicheren Messenger, die das tun, ganz oft nur auf einem Gerät benutzt werden können, weil dort liegt der Schlüssel. Das heißt, dann gibt es irgendwelche Leute, die sagen, ich nehme jetzt, was ist das, Telegram oder so, weil ich da auch einen Desktop klein zuhabe. Das funktioniert dann nicht so ohne Weiteres. Gibt sicherlich möglicherweise so Middlegrounds, aber die sind halt da nicht implementiert. Es gibt halt nur entweder oder. Und das andere, wo man sich halt auch so ein bisschen Gedanken darüber machen sollte, kennt man die Implementierung. Also nicht man selber, sondern gibt es Möglichkeiten für Experten, die da reingucken können und entscheiden können. Das ist nach all dem, was man heute so kryptographisch weiß und auch aus Sicht von Computersicherheit generell, eine vernünftige Implementierung. Wie gesagt, hundertprozentige Sicherheit, das ist auch was, was wir immer wilder betonen, gibt es nicht. Aber es gibt auf jeden Fall die Möglichkeit, nach best practice zu handeln. Das ist kein Hexenwerk, das ist einfach nur aufwendig. Das ist seine Arbeit machen. Und das ist natürlich in Zeiten, wo Apps schnell raus müssen, schnell an den Kunden müssen, immer so ein bisschen ein Zielkonflikt. Aber das sind ja die Kriterien, wie man das austraut. Ich stelle die Frage mal anders. Was hast du denn auf deinem Telefon, Danimo? Ich habe tatsächlich Threema und seit neuestem jetzt auch Signal, wobei mir da halt so ein bisschen missfällt, dass Signal jetzt neuerdings irgendwie zwangsläufig mein Telefonbuch auslesen will. Also ich verstehe auch die Intention dahinter, nämlich dieses... also ein Grund, warum WhatsApp ja so populär ist, ist auch ein Grund, warum ich es nicht verwende. Jeder, der meine Telefonnummer hat, kann mich anschreiben.
Genau, also darauf wollte ich eigentlich auch hinaus. Das ist eben der Grund zur Unterschied. Bei Streamer habe ich wirklich einen getrennten Account. Das heißt, den kann ich, wenn ich möchte, mit meiner Telefonnummer verbinden. Und ich kann auch mein Telefonbuch sinken, aber ich muss das nicht. Und das ist der große Vorteil. Ich muss nicht preisgeben, wen ich alles kenne. Und nicht jeder, der meine... Ich muss auch meine Handynummer nicht preisgeben. Das heißt, Leute, die meine Handynummer haben, können mich zwar weiterhin anrufen und mir SMS schreiben oder so, aber können mich nicht unbedingt über Streamer zu erreichen. Ich kann wirklich ganz genau auswählen, mit wem ich eigentlich kommunizieren möchte. Und dann habe ich halt sozusagen verschiedene Sicherheitsstufen. Das heißt, erst mal ist ich habe nur die ID von dem bekommen, irgendwie, den fahre ich auch auf einem anderen Weg. Das ist sozusagen unsicher. Sicherer ist, wenn es noch eine Telefonnummer zum Abgleich gibt. Aber der sicherste Weg ist und das ist vollkommen unabhängig von der Telefonnummer, ist, dass zum Beispiel Danimo und ich wirklich uns Angesicht zu Angesicht zueinander stehen und einen sogenannten QR-Code, die kennt, glaube ich, mittlerweile ja doch jeder, anzeigen und der andere den einfach scannt. Und dann auch in die andere Richtung. Damit wissen wir genau, dieser Account, den ich dann auch angezeigt bekomme, gehört zu der Person, die mir gegenüber steht. Und wenn ich mit dem schreibe, rede ich wirklich mit dieser Person.
Und das ist kein Muss. Das ist genau. Ich kann mit ihr auch so kommunizieren, aber dann bin ich mir halt nicht wirklich sicher, ob das wirklich Carina ist. Okay, der Nachteil bei 3MA ist, kann man sagen, der ist nicht open source. Das heißt, da kann nicht jeder einfach reingucken in den Quellcode. Wie ist es bei dir, Matthias? Was hast du auf dem Handy?
Na ja, ich habe auf jeden Fall auch 3MA natürlich. Aber ich muss auch sagen, ich habe auch WhatsApp, weil na ja, es gibt halt außerhalb des Nerdkreises auch noch sozusagen die erweiterten Freunde und so weiter.
Du bist ein Kandidat für eine 50er-Paket-Lizenzen verschenken.
Und sagen wir es mal so, also prinzipiell ist WhatsApp natürlich auch Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt. Von daher ist es jetzt auch nicht so ein...
Aber da fallen ja die ganzen Metadaten an.
Richtig, die ganzen Metadaten liegen eben genau wieder bei WhatsApp. Und da Facebook ja WhatsApp quasi wieder eingemeindet hat, liegen sie auch wieder bei Facebook. Und das ist natürlich ein großes Problem an dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Und man muss auch davon ausgehen, dass Facebook langfristig auf jeden Fall die Sachen zusammenlegen will. Im Moment haben sie da ein paar rechtliche Probleme. Es gab ja sozusagen neuer schon die Bemühung, die Telefonnummer sozusagen weiterzugeben.
Was da erstmal zurückgezogen wurde.
Sokrates, nur ganz kurz, wie ist es bei dir?
Ja, ich hab auch nur Streamer und halt ganz viel Jabber.
Alles klar, haben wir das auch geklärt. Wir machen eine ganz kurze Pause und sind dann hier wieder zurück im Chaosradio im Blue Moon.
Radio hat einen Namen.
So, herzlich willkommen zurück im Chaosradio Blue Moon Another Night Another Run war das mit Breakbeat Heartbeat. Wir reden heute hier über viele verschiedene Themen und haben zum Beispiel gerade mit und da möchte ich noch einmal begrüßen Danimo, Carina, Matthias und Sokrates. Hallo. Hallo.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Wir haben über Weihnachtsgeschenke geredet und da möchte ich doch gleich die geschickte Überleitung machen. Apropos Weihnachtsgeschenke shoppen, Sokrates, du wolltest uns über Online-Rabatte aufreißen. Du sollst jetzt sagen, amerikanische Weihnachtstraditionen wie Halloween kommen ja sozusagen immer mehr aufs Festland nach Europa. Und da gibt es auch den Black Friday und Cyber Monday oder irgendwie so Blue Monday oder irgendwas, also quasi so riesige Online-Rabatzangebotsdinge. Und die sind jetzt nicht toll oder wie oder was? Was genau?
Es gibt da sehr, sehr viele Unterschiede. Das ist sehr Datenbanklastig. Also die Preise unterscheiden sich bei manchen Shops da auf dem Grund, was du für ein Gerät hast, mit dem du diese Preise abrufst oder nach der Suchmaschine, die du benutzt. Und vor allen Dingen auch, welche Tageszeit du benutzt. Und das ist halt sehr, sehr schwierig. Also da sollte man ganz genau hingucken und nicht nur nach dem ersten Mal auf irgendeiner Preissuchmaschine.
Warte, nein. Das heißt, ich kann nicht wie in der Vergangenheit immer sagen, ich brauche unbedingt ein neues technisches Gerät XY. Ich gucke einfach bei der Preissuchmaschine, zack.
Nee, das wäre nicht so gut. Und vor allen Dingen solltest du nicht unbedingt mit einem, leider Apple-Gerät, ah, sorry.
Wieso, was passiert da?
Weil dann sind die Preise automatisch teurer.
Na ja gut, ich meine, das hatten wir eigentlich schon bei Hotelsuchportalen und so weiter im letzten Jahr. Oder was, vor zwei Jahren bereits schon. Also ich meine, das ist ja jetzt nichts Neues.
Aber wie umgehe ich das denn?
Ähm, setzt dir einfach ein uraltes Windows auf. Aber nicht, nur suchen, nicht shoppen bitte.
Aber da muss ja wiederum, ich wollte gerade sagen, da muss ich wiederum sagen, okay, ich komme also mit einem Applegerät auf einer Preissuchmaschine und denke so, ha ha, Applegerät, der hat viel Geld, dem können wir es abziehen. Aber wenn ich mit einem alten Windows Computer komme, denke ich so, ha ha ha, der merkt gar nichts, dem können wir viel abziehen.
Dann nimmst du halt so ein Mittel, aber bitte kein Windows 10. Kein Windows 10, die Dinger sollte man sowieso nicht nutzen. Warum? Weil die, also das ist die Hölle.
Ach, was?
Also Datenschutztechnik, die diese Metadatengeschichte, die die da haben, oh Gott.
Spezifiziere?
Pass auf, ja, das ist das Problem, das haben wir noch nicht ganz raus. Aber Microsoft sagt offiziell, dass sie Metadaten von deinem PC analysieren, und zwar live von allen.
Was heißt Metadaten?
Ja, Metadaten, was sind Metadaten eines PCs? Im Endeffekt gehört zu Metadaten alles, was du tust. Also das Öffnen einer Datei, das Öffnen einer Webseite, alles. Also alles, was du tust, gehört zu Metadaten. Die Dateien selbst wahrscheinlich nicht, aber das, was du tust. Also du öffnest jetzt den Pornonummer X3, was weiß ich, oder irgendwas.
Aber wie das sammelt, Microsoft?
Die Metadaten, ja. Mit Windows 10.
Werden übertragen an...
Ja, genau.
Und was machen die denn damit?
Auswerten. Also die wollen damit wahrscheinlich auswerten, ob du irgendwelche Funktionen nutzt, die die einbauen und ob du mitbekommst, hey, das neue Icon-Nummer, was weiß ich, nutzt du das überhaupt oder nutzt das überhaupt irgendjemand und deshalb wollen die das wahrscheinlich haben.
Also diese Sammlung von Metadaten ist hier eigentlich in allen Bereichen immer damit begründet, dass sie sozusagen sagen, ja, wir wollen das Nutzerverhalten analysieren, damit wir unsere Produkte besser machen können und optimieren können. Aber natürlich gibt es auch noch ganz viele andere tolle Wege, wie man das Ganze nutzen kann, zum Beispiel um eine personalisierte Werbung anzubinden. Oder es gibt da auch so gewisse Behörden, von denen wir schon den ein oder andere gehört hatten, die natürlich auch richtig gerne dann mal ein paar Informationen dazu haben, bei Leuten, wo es sich interessiert. Das ist halt immer die Gefahr. Das ist halt immer die Gefahr, weswegen man so was von Anfang an vermeiden will. Denn wenn Daten da sind, werden sie genutzt. Das sehen wir immer und immer wieder, auch egal wie sehr uns vorher versprochen wird, dass es nicht passieren wird.
Verspricht Microsoft gerade noch, nur wir haben diese Daten?
Nein, nein, nicht mal das, sondern Firefly, diese Firewall Firma hat gerade diese Daten bekommen.
Wer ist das?
So ein blöder Firewall-Hersteller, Schlangenöl und so.
Das ist ein Firewall-Hersteller, was ist Schlangenöl?
Dinge, die du nicht kaufen willst, die eigentlich schlecht sind.
Das, was die fahrenden Händler früher verkauft haben in der Behauptung, es heilt dich von allen Krankheiten. Also sowas wie Homöopathie. Genau. Richtig. Warum ist eine Firewall-Homöopathie?
Eine Firewall selbst ist keine Homöopathie, aber das, was diese Vionscanner und diesen ganzen Kram, das ist Homöopathie, weil es nicht funktionieren kann.
Inwiefern?
Weil die Benutzung eines PCs so dynamisch ist und so individuell, dass du keine wirklich guten Heuristiken erkennen kannst.
Was ist eine Heuristik?
So ein Antivirus-Programm erkennt erst mal Dinge, die es kennt oder von denen es weiß, wie es sie erkennen kann.
Aber das hilft mir doch schon.
Ja, im Moment, das hilft aber nur gegen bekannte Sachen.
Aber das ist schon mal gut.
Aber das Problem ist, die ganzen Bierenhersteller, äh Hersteller, also die ganzen Autoren von Schadsoftware letzten Endes sind ja auch nicht blöd. Die entwickeln ihre Software letzten Endes auch weiter. Und die finden auch neue Wege und auch neue Wege, sich im System zu tarnen. Und eine Heuristik ist letzten Endes etwas, was sozusagen einen bekannten Weg formalisiert, um eine solche Schadsoftware im System zu finden.
Warte mal, also sagen Bieren-Scanner machen zwei Sachen. Nämlich das eine ist sozusagen Viren erkennen, von denen man ganz genau weiß, wie sie aussehen.
Oder wie man sie erkennen kann.
Also sogar ein verdächtiges Verhalten?
Ungefähr, ja genau, das Verhalten ist verdächtig.
Und die Aussage ist sozusagen, Viren-Scanner können dieses verdächtige Verhalten nicht wirklich sicherstellen.
Wenn ein völlig neuartiges Verfahren zum Beispiel auf den Markt kommt und eine völlig neue Art und Weise, wie mit diesen Dateien oder mit Netzwerkverbindungen umgegangen wird, dann kennt eben das Antivirus-Programm dieses Verfahren nicht und hat entsprechend kein Heuristik dafür, um das zu erkennen.
Hab ich verstanden, möchte einen Vergleich bemühen. Sicherheitsscanner am Flughafen schlagen nur an, wenn die Pistole, die ich in meinem Gürtel habe, aus Metall ist. Haben wir aus vielen Agentenfilmen gesehen, aus Plastepistolen oder aus Knete sozusagen gehen da durch. Trotzdem finde ich das eine gute Idee, dass die Metallpistolen nicht durchkommen. Viren-Scanner kann ja sozusagen, also okay, kann ich alle Viren erkennen, aber zumindest die, die bekannt sind, ist doch auch schon mal gut oder nicht?
Theoretisch, aber das Problem ist ein anderes. Und zwar, viele Viren-Scanner haben Angriffsmethoden genutzt, um zu sehen, was du gerade tust.
Was?
Ganz viele von denen verwenden zum Beispiel einen Man-in-the-Middle-Angriff. Also, klinken sich zwischen deinem Browser in das Netzwerk hinein und schauen zu, was du für Trafik machst. Das bedeutet aber, sie können all das, auch wenn du HTTPS im Browser siehst und sagst, das ist jetzt eine super sichere Verbindung, dann haben sie die trotzdem schon aufgebrochen und können mitlesen, um halt so eine Sachen zu sehen. Und das sind halt echt böse Dinge, die verhindern, weil sie dann wieder ein Stück...
Das heißt sozusagen, Virenscanner machen das, was Viren machen, damit sie Sicherheit garantieren? Oder Angreifer.
Die machen das, was Angreifer machen, benutzen diese Tools, um halt Dinge zu erkennen, die total schwierig sind.
Und das Schlimme ist dann in ihrem Bemühen, dass ich auch wirklich, wo ich auch wirklich glaube, dass sie das richtig machen wollen. Aber die Materie, sich da reinzuklinken und quasi alles das, was jetzt so ein Browser-Hersteller und so ein Betriebssystemhersteller mühsam mit mit richtig viel Qualitätssicherung irgendwie da reingebaut hat, sich da dazwischen zu klemmen, sorgt halt immer wieder dafür, dass Virenscanner oder generell Sicherheitssoftware Lücken aufreißt, die vorher eigentlich in Abwesenheit dieser Sicherheitssoftware gar nicht dagewesen wären. Also warte, ich meine Virenscanner installiere ich auf meinem System, der macht dann Dinge, die normalerweise Angreifer machen, unten macht neue Löcher auf. Ist das ein Verdacht, den ihr habt? Nein, es gibt mehrfach immer wieder Paper von Security Researchern, also Sicherheitsleuten, die das beruflich machen, die dann leider immer wieder in dieselbe Richtung stoßen. Das ist wieder so ein Punkt, wo ich jetzt einfach sozusagen rausgehen möchte und ich mache jetzt Musik an und dann wiedersehen.
Ja, das ist eben die gute Launesendung.
Aber deswegen ist es eben die viel bessere Empfehlung, einfach sozusagen versuchen, sich intelligent im Netz zu verhalten. Das heißt einfach, nicht auf random Sachen zu klicken. Weil die Sachen, die bekannt sind, die alt sind, die, die die Viren-Scanner sozusagen erkennen, das sind die Sachen, die werden rumgeschickt. Wie gesagt, das ist alt, das hat oft auch die gleichen Angriffe immer wieder. Also ja, es schützt davor, dass ich irgendwie einen gefährlichen Anhang aufmache. So, der bessere Tipp ist, mach keine Anhänge auf, die du irgendwie nicht weißt, von wem es ist oder die komisch aussehen. Du brauchst nicht die 500 lustige Powerpoint-Präsentation, die dir irgendein Kumpel, mit dem du irgendwann mal zu tun hattest, geschickt hast. Na ja. Mach die zu. Aber. Lass die zu.
Also ich nicht, du nicht, du halt auch nicht. Aber es ist ja so, es kommt ja in der Zeit, die Zeit, wo die Eingeborenen nach Hause um ihren Altvorderen und so weiter und so fort. Und dann sagen die ja, ja, kannst du nicht dann vielleicht noch so mal einen aktuellen Virenscanner irgendwie drauf machen. Das heißt, ich nehme, ich schlussfolge aus dem, was ihr sagt. Nee, lieber nicht, sondern lieber sich eine Stunde hinsetzen und ein sicheres Verhalten im Internet beibringen. Und wenn du ihnen unbedingt was installieren willst, installiere ihnen einen gescheiten Adblocker. Einfach aus dem Grund, nicht weil wir, ich glaube, das haben wir hier schon mal thematisiert, in einer anderen Sendung. Es geht nicht darum, irgendwen zu schädigen, was als Seiteneffekt halt durchaus passieren kann. Aber, also sprich die Leute, die mit der Werbung dann das Geld verdienen. Aber es ist einfach so, dass es ein ungelöstes Problem ist und auch auf absehbare Zeit sein wird, diese Werbung so zu gestalten, dass dort nicht finstere Leute ihre Mailware mit dieser Werbung ausspielen können. Weil man muss sich das so vorstellen, Werbung im Internet ist nichts anderes als ein Last-Minute-Bieter-Wettstreit um den höchsten Preis auf einem Werbeplatz. Und wenn ich jetzt als Viren-Autor gerne dich targeten möchte, entweder weil du ein bestimmtes Betriebssystem hast oder ein bestimmtes Surf-Verhalten hast oder so, dann kann ich das tun und kann dir, weil ich zum Beispiel weiß, dass du den Browser XY verwendest mit der und der Sicherheitslücke und kann dich mit individuell für solche Werbung bespielen.
Na, das ist ja auch genau der Punkt von so einem Werbenetzwerk. Die Werbenetzwerke sind darauf optimiert, eben genau getargetete Werbung auszuspielen. Das heißt, sie haben genau demografische Regeln und weitere Kriterien, mit denen du genau exakt dein Zielpublikum für deine Werbung aussuchen kannst.
Inklusive wer ist das CEO im Firmenetzwerk XY? So gut kommt man daran. Okay, ich hätte also gesagt, wir nehmen heute viele Themen dran. Hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass wir so schnell springen. Ich gehe also nochmal zurück über das, was wir gerade gesprochen haben. Nicht wie ein Scanner installieren, sondern lieber Adblocker.
Und ein Under-Script, ganz wichtig.
Und nochmal sozusagen gutes Verhalten üben.
Genau, wobei man da auch echt aufpassen muss. Was ist denn jetzt schon wie? Es ist überraschend, was Leute so schaffen. Ich habe zum Beispiel, ich sage jetzt nicht wem, aber meinem Bekanntenpreis beigebracht bei E-Mails, wenn das Mails sind, wo er nicht so richtig weiß, da auf jeden Fall nicht drauf zu klicken. Also auch Fishing-Mails, also Mails mit Links, die sagen hier, das ist dein Paypal-Account oder so, da ist was passiert, klick doch bitte hier mal und guck mal, wir glauben, da ist Betrug, das ist so eine ganz beliebte Masche, damit die Leute dann da draufklicken auf die falsche Seite, kommen ihre Eingaben machen und dann sozusagen, man den Login-Daten abgreifen kann. Das habe ich ihm beigebracht und gesagt, okay, das darfst du auf keinen Fall klicken hier auf so Sachen, wenn du dir unsicher bist, leite mir das weiter. Und dann war ich gerade verreist, komme wieder und sage, ja, du hast gesagt, ich darf da nicht draufklicken, aber unten stand eine Telefonnummer, da habe ich angerufen. Da war ein sehr verwirrter Mann drum, der gar nicht wusste, worum es geht. Also das finde ich auch eine sehr schöne. Also da habe ich dann auch gelernt. Also manchmal kann man gar nicht weit genug denken, was man alles erklären muss. Ich habe dann eben dieses Regel-Set erweitert, um auch bitte keine Nummern anzurufen, die in E-Mails stehen.
Ignoriere alles, was in der Mail steht.
Ja, genau, also ruf da nicht an. Also schick das, wenn du dir unsicher bist, schick das mir, dann sage ich es dir. Und bei der Mail war das Schönste, dass ich meine Rückfrage war, sag mal, hast du eigentlich Paypoint? Dann muss ich es mir gar nicht angucken, dass es Spam. Also da muss man manchmal wirklich noch ein bisschen zurückgehen und überlegen, was muss ich jetzt genau erklären. Manchmal kann es wirklich rudimentär sein, so wenn du irgendeinen Dienst nicht nutzt, dann ignorier die Mails, die es dir schickt. Das ist dann nicht für dich. Und wenn irgendwas ist, geh auf die Webseite, wenn es ein Dienst ist und guck sie da an. Und damit kann man schon viel, viel mehr abschrecken, als eben so ein Virenscanner das eigentlich kann, indem man den Leuten einfach intelligente Surferhalten erklärt. Und dann können die Leute eben auch deutlich beruhigter auch ihr Handy oder so in die Hand nehmen, weil da ist ja das gleiche Spiel.
Und vor allen Dingen auch so Rechnungen kommen immer per Post, wenn es dringend ist. Niemals per Mail.
Wenn die E-Mail versucht, Druck aufzubauen im Sinne von in drei Tagen sperren wir das Konto, wenn du jetzt nicht hier klickst oder wir haben irgendetwas geändert, dann ist es mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit ein Versuch, dich auf einem, naja, sagen wir mal, etwas abseitige Seite zu weiterzuladen.
Das geht nicht für Mails von der Mutter, die fragt, ob du zu Weihnachten kommst. Ganz wichtig, die nicht ignorieren. Das ist noch gefährlicher.
Na, die hört sich doch auf WhatsApp.
Um sozusagen, also falls sich jemand einen Fünchchen Rest Hoffnung hat, dass vielleicht doch alles gut ist und denkt, ich setze mich jetzt an meinen Rechner, setze einfach meinen Kopfhörer auf und höre ein bisschen Musik, dann kann ja nichts passieren. Außer, dass dir jemand gerade mal... Ja, danke, bitte. Ja, ich wollte... Erzähl bitte, danke schön. Naja, tut mir leid. Du magst zwar gerade was hören, das ist dann auch in Ordnung. Aber wenn du den Kopfhörer vielleicht mal gerade beiseite legst, dann ist vielleicht nicht mehr in Ordnung. Matthias kann das, glaube ich, besser erklären.
Du legst einfach den Kopfhörer beiseite und dann stellst du fest, hm, okay, ich habe gerade eben eine voll Raumüberwachung freigegeben, weil Kopfhörer, was, okay, ich gehe einfach mal einen Schritt zurück. Was ist eigentlich so ein Kopfhörer? Ein Kopfhörer ist so ein Gerät, das, naja, macht Töne. Und diese Töne macht es, indem halt da elektrische Impulse reingeleitet werden, die einem Membran anregen. So weit, so gut. Also wir schieben quasi Energie rein, die Membran wird angeregt und es werden Schallwellen abgestrahlt, die dann auf dein Ohr treffen.
Strom macht Ton.
Richtig.
Gut.
Was allerdings auch geht, ist, wenn man selber etwas sagt oder irgendwie generell Geräusche produziert im Raum, dann strahlen diese Schallquellen auch eben Energie ab und diese Energie trifft wiederum auf diese Membran und diese Membran wird dann von außen angeregt und fängt an zu schwingen. Und das Schöne ist, es entsteht dabei Strom.
Okay, Ton macht Strom, Strom macht Ton. Aber die Mikrofone, in die wir hier reinsprechen, die sie dir extra dafür gemacht haben, du sagst, Kopfhörer, mit Kopfhörern geht das auch.
Genau.
Das ist mir noch verständlich, dass ich einen Kopfhörer auch als Mikrofone benutzen kann. Aber der Kopfhörer in meinem Rechner steckt ja in einer Kopfhörerbuchse. Und die ist ja nur dafür da, dass die Soundkarte, also das digitale Gerät in dem Rechner, Sound nach draußen gibt.
Ja, das war auch eigentlich ursprünglich mal eine ganz gute Idee. Allerdings kam dann irgendwann der User. Und der User hatte sich dann gedacht, ja irgendwie stecke ich jetzt einfach mal dieses Mikrofon in, naja, das ist irgendwie so eine Buchse, da passt das schon irgendwo mit rein. Daraufhin hat sich zum Beispiel ein Hersteller namens Realtek gedacht. Ja Mensch, ist ja irgendwie doof, wenn die ganze Zeit User bei uns an der Hotline anrufen und sagen, ja irgendwie mein Mikrofon geht nicht. Geben wir doch einfach dem User eine Softwaremöglichkeit, einfach jeden beliebigen Anschluss an meinem Rechner für einen Mikrofoneingang zu nehmen. Das ist ein ziemlich altes Feature eigentlich in diesem Chipsatz und auch schon ziemlich, naja, auch relativ gut unterstützt von der Hardware. Also wenn man je nach Rechner, wenn man da eben ein Mikrofon ansteckt, dann kommt da so ein kleines Pop-Up und sagt, ja, also wir haben hier gerade ein kleines Mikrofon angeschlossen, wollen sie nicht eben halt das Ganze auch irgendwie jetzt als Eingang verwenden. Genau, und jetzt wurde ein kleines Proof of Concept geschrieben, also so eine kleine Demonstrationsmalware.
Also das heißt, das gibt es noch nicht als echten Virus in der Wildbahn, sondern es ist ein praktischer Beweis.
Genau, es wurde jetzt einfach mal demonstriert. Ja, das Ganze kann man natürlich auch ohne Userinteraktion machen und einfach mal so den Kopfhörerausgang zu einem Mikrofoneingang machen. Und wie gesagt, Strom macht Ton, Ton macht auch Strom. Und diesen Strom, den kann man dann ein bisschen verstärken. Und dann hat man im Prinzip aus seinen Kopfhörern ein Mikrofon gemacht und kann dann in den Raum reinhorchen.
Nicht so qualitativ, aber man kann hören.
Es geht ja. Also im Prinzip, it's not a bug, it's a feature.
Warte mal, du hast doch gefragt, wo die Studiotür ist. Danke, danke, danke. Also Dagen, das ist jetzt ein praktischer Beweis, dass die Theorie funktioniert. Man muss aber schon auch sagen, das ist auch schön, das zu erzählen, weil Dagen halt so eine krasse Nummer ist. Aber der praktische Nutzen außerhalb von Geheimdienstenaren ist jetzt aber nicht so groß.
Naja, also ich sage mal so, je nach Angriff, oder wie man so schön sagt, Threat Model, gibt es ja durchaus Leute, die klemmen dann in ihrem Rechner das Mikrofon ab und so weiter und haben dann ihren Rechner soweit dann...
Nein, nein, das meine ich nicht. Also wenn jetzt jemand eine Möglichkeit herausfindet, wie er in sozusagen beliebigen Rechnern vorgaukeln kann, das wäre das Login zu einer Bank. Dann verschickt er einfach massenhaft Mails und dann infiziert er damit vielleicht irgendwie 5% und macht damit Gewinn.
Naja, so sagen, was man so hier muss, im Prinzip der Rechner schon infiziert sein.
Nee, worauf ich hinaus will, ist sozusagen das Angriffsszenario. Hier ist er sozusagen so, okay, dann kann ich jemanden dem Rechner abhören. Das heißt, für einen gezielten Angriff ist das vielleicht sinnvoll als Geheimagent oder weißt ja geier was, oder wenn ich halt wirklich jemand abhören will. Aber das ist nicht so ein Ding, wo man jetzt damit rechnen muss, dass jetzt irgendwie tausend Millionen Angriffe damit gefahren werden. Naja, das nicht. Also du hast recht, aber wir haben ja, was diese, was jetzt z.B. Spionage per Webcam angeht, durchaus immer wieder Fälle gesehen, wo und da ist der Angriff natürlich, meistens jemand im näheren Umfeld und hat meistens auch Zugriff auf den Rechner. Das ist schon alles richtig. Nur, dass ich die Kamera abklebe, da habe ich jetzt letztens ein paar Veranstaltungen gehabt mit Schülern, die haben mir damals gesagt, ja klar, machen wir sogar schon teilweise. Da war ich total überrascht. Wer würde jetzt auf die Idee kommen, seine Kopfhörer abzuziehen, wenn man mal kurz weggeht und nicht gerade wird?
Okay, da sollte man dran denken. Aber was mir gerade einfällt, wo wir vorhin bei Geschenken waren, man sollte sich die Anleitung von seinem Smart TV genau durchlesen, weil bei manchen Anleitungen im Smart TV steht ganz doll drinnen, man soll vor dem Gerät, egal ob es angeschaltet oder ausgeschaltet ist, keine privaten Gespräche führen. Das ist kein Witz.
Genau, das ist nämlich das Problem. Viele denken ja, okay, ich hör da was mit, da muss jetzt einer sitzen und zuhören und entscheiden so, da ist jetzt was, damit können wir irgendwie was anfangen. Aber dem ist ja nicht so. Also wir haben ja schon gelernt, dass eben diese Überwachung automatisiert ist. Und genau, dass das sogar schon im User-Umfeld, also im ganz normalen Anwendungsumfeld im Haushalt angekommen ist, zeigen eben die Smart TVs, die irgendwie darauf reagieren. Und auch die Telefonen, wenn man irgendwie sagt, okay, Google oder... Genau, oder all diese verschiedenen, die es jetzt gibt, die dann auf irgendwelche Stichwörter hören, die hören halt permanent zu und schicken deine Informationen an einen Server, der sozusagen analysiert, was sagst du da? Ist das gerade was, worauf wir hören sollen? Und dann darauf reagiert.
Richtig, sie müssen ja auch zuhören, weil sonst könnten sie ja nicht auf Hallo Alexa, okay Google oder Hallo Siri antworten.
Genau, aber das bedeutet halt, weil es diese Technologie ja offensichtlich schon gibt und sogar im Hausgebrauch überall, dass es eben die Möglichkeit gibt, Text mittlerweile ganz gut, also auch gesprochenes Wort ganz gut, automatisch zu analysieren, zu gucken, welcher Text wurde da gesprochen. Und darauf kann man dann ja wieder, also ob es jetzt Text ist oder sozusagen Sprache, der eben in Text umgeformt wurde, darauf kann man dann wieder wunderschönes Data-Mining machen und gucken, was kommt denn alles so drin vor. Das heißt, es muss gar nicht einer zuhören, sondern man kann sozusagen interessante Sachen dann highlighten. Das kann sich dann sogar noch mal einer anhören, wenn man will und da dann Informationen rauskriegen. Und das ist eben fürs Social-Engineering ganz spannend, weil man einfach interessante Informationen kriegt. Aber auch Social-Engineering. Das nennt sich, das ist sozusagen, wenn man versucht, durch, also hier ist es...
Vertrauensbildende Maßnahmen.
Genau, so Informationen zu bekommen, damit man dann auf einer sozialen Ebene die Leute austricksen kann. Also, indem ich sozusagen irgendwie Erfahrungen bringe. Also, es kann auch sein, dass man eben im Müll sucht.
Also, das sagen wir einfach mal im Marketing.
Ich belausche jemanden und sage dann, hey, du hast du nicht neulich von Dingens geredet? Wir kennen uns doch sehr gut.
Oder ich suche Müll irgendwie und sage, ey, hier, ich ruf dich an, ich bin deine Bank übrigens hier, Sie haben doch dann und an Geburtstag und so, ich muss das validieren. Ja, das habe ich auch als Daten oder so. Wir brauchen das und das wegen dieser Sicherheitslücke. Also wenn man so Sachen anruft und dann eben persönlich agiert, sozusagen das nennt sich Social Engineering, um eben sozusagen die sozialen Möglichkeiten auszunutzen, um eben irgendwo Zugriff zu bekommen oder so, was man eigentlich nicht haben sollte.
Das Vertrauen, das erst mal fehlt, aufgebaut. Und die Grund, die Basis dafür kann auch sein, dass man mich mittels meiner Kopfhörer belauscht. Sehr schön.
Wer möglich.
Ich ziehe jetzt meine Holzhütte und werde dort Figuren schnitzen und gleich ein gutes Buch lesen. Aber bevor wir darüber genauer reden, machen wir noch das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichtenwetter und Verkehr.
Und sechs weiteren Top-Nachwuchs-Acts. Dezember in den Blackbox-Hallen Pankow. Und mit ein bisschen Fritz und Glück könnt ihr dabei sein. Denn Karten gibt's nirgendwo zu kaufen, sondern nur zu gewinnen.
Klickt einfach fritz.de slash n-n-a.
Und vielleicht seht ihr da eure nächste neue Lieblingsband. Und natürlich übertragen wir den auch live und im Radio.
Um kurze halb 12. Mit Timo Maschewski.
Der Pilotenstreik bei der Lufthansa ist ein weiteres Mal verlängert worden. Die Gewerkschaft Cockpit hat am Abend mitgeteilt, dass auch übermorgen noch gestreikt werden soll, dann sollen vor allem Langstreckenflüge betroffen sein. Morgen, am dritten Streiktag, trifft es dagegen überwiegend Kurz- und Mittelstrecken. Rund 830 Flüge wurden für morgen gestrichen, für gestrandete Passagiere sind am Frankfurter Flughafen Feldbetten aufgestellt worden. Lufthansa und Cockpit streiten sich um mehr Geld für die Piloten. Die deutsche Polizei hat einen 20-jährigen syrischen Flüchtling festgenommen, der sich Zutaten für den Bau von Bomben besorgt haben soll. Der Mann habe sich eine Zeit lang in Deutschland aufgehalten, heißt es von der Staatsanwaltschaft in Stuttgart. Als er letzte Woche mit dem Versuch gescheitert sei, nach Dänemark auszureisen, habe man ihn in Ulm festgenommen. Nach ersten Hinweisen könnte der Mann mit der Terrorgruppe IS sympathisiert haben, er sitzt in Untersuchungshaft. Vor der Küste von El Salvador im Pazifik hat es ein starkes Erdbeben gegeben. Das Beben hatte nach Angaben der US-Erdbebenwarte eine Stärke von 7, 0. Eine Tsunami-Warnung für El Salvador und Nicaragua wurde mittlerweile wieder aufgehoben. Über Opfer oder Schäden ist bisher nichts bekannt. Nicaragua befindet sich im Moment ohnehin in Alarmbereitschaft, weil Hurricane Otto dort heute auf Land getroffen war. Entlang der Küste wurden Tausende Einwohner in Sicherheit gebracht, die Schulen wurden geschlossen. Fußball-Bundesligist Mainz 05 ist in der Gruppenphase der Europa League gescheitert. Im Rückspiel beim französischen Rekordmeister Sainte Etienne schaffte Mainz nur ein 0 zu 0. Schalke setzte sich gegen Nizza mit 2 zu 0 durch. Schalke stand aber auch schon vorher als Gruppensieger fest. Die aktuellen Temperaturen Berlin-Hellersdorf hat 0 Grad und Charlottenburg 2 Grad. In Prenzlau sind es minus 1 Grad, Wittenberge hat 0 Grad, Potsdam meldet plus 1 Grad und Forst hat noch plus 4 Grad. Viel kälter wird es nicht mehr, die Tiefstädte liegen nachts zwischen minus 2 und plus 2 Grad. Der Himmel ist meistens klar, es kann sich stellenweise aber Nebel bilden. Auch den Tag über bleibt es oft trübe, mehr als 4 Grad sind dann nicht drin. Und auch am Samstag wenig Sonne, am Sonntag dann aber wieder schöner. Vorsicht auf der A24 Hamburg, Berlin. Zwischen Herzsprung und Neuropin laufen immer noch Leute auf der Autobahn. Auf der A10, dem südlichen Berliner Ring, Richtung Dreieck Werder wird gebaut. Zwischen Ludwigsfelde Ost und Ludwigsfelde West ist die linke Spur gesperrt, da kann es ab und zu mal länger dauern. Und ab morgen werden die Bauarbeiten bei der U-Bahn-Linie 7 ausgeweitet. Bis Sonntagbetriebsschluss müsst ihr dann zwischen Britz Süd und Rudu auf Ersatzbusse umsteigen. Dort, wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn ihr gute Tipps in Sachen Mode, Filme, neue Platten, Bücher oder Games wollt, dann klickt doch mal fritz.de slash Tipps.
Heute mit Markus Richter im Chaosradio im Blue Moon, wo wir viele verschiedene Themen bearbeiten. Das heißt vor allen Dingen erklären, wie schlimm die Welt eigentlich wirklich ist. Und dazu herzlich willkommen zurück nochmal Sokrates, Matthias, Carina und Danimo. Und wir haben festgestellt, wir brauchen eine extra Gesellschaft, die die Regierung verklagt, weil die komische Gesetze beschließt. Wir brauchen nach Gerichtsentscheidungen wird aber trotzdem alles ignoriert. Und eigentlich ist auch alles kaputt und wir werden überwacht. Und es ist fürchterlich und Schlangenöl. Und hört euch die letzten anderthalb Stunden nochmal ein Podcast an, wenn ihr wirklich verzweifeln wollt.
Und jetzt weißt du, warum bei uns mal es diesen Spruch gibt, vielleicht einfach was mit Holz machen.
Oder Orchideen. Ich wollte gerade sagen, so im Jahresende, also bevor ich in die Berge ziehe, in die Holzhütte, nicht mit Internet und vielleicht auch nicht mal mit Strom, gibt es noch den Chaos Communication Congress. Zwischen den Jahren, die es so schon heißt, also ab 27. 26. ist das Tag Null.
Wir reisen nur alle schon am 26. spätestens an. Das heißt nicht, dass es dann losgeht.
Also es gibt den Chaos Communication Congress. Und das ist nochmal was? Das ist das Jahrestreffen des CCC und alle der Leute, die dem Hacken und der Kultur zugetan sind und sich gerne informieren möchten, austauschen möchten und eine gute Zeit haben. Und was passiert da? Und wo ist das? Das ist in Hamburg im Kongresszentrum. Und da sind vor allen Dingen Vorträge. Da sind sogenannte Assemblies, wo sich Leute verschiedener Fachrichtungen um einen Tisch hocken und Besuchern und Interessierten zeigen, was sie so machen, was sie so können und wie man mitmachen kann. Also Hacker unter sich und sonst niemand? Nein, eben nicht. Also den Leuten, die vorbeikommen. Das heißt, jedem, der sich für das Thema interessiert.
Wie viele Leute sind denn da?
15.000?
Ja, nicht ganz so rund.
13.000?
Auf jeden Fall über 9.000.
Okay, ähm, die, ähm, so rund, es geht aber jetzt schon. Wir haben das gesehen, große Gehämmer, es gibt keine Tickets mehr. Was, wie, warum? Ich meine, fünfstellige Anzahl Leute, keine Tickets mehr. Wie passt das zusammen?
Wir haben mehr Bedarf von Leuten, die kommen wollen, als Platz für die Leute. Es ist sehr schade, aber es ist leider so.
Genau, es ist einfach immer beliebter geworden. Die Leute sehen Artikel in Zeitschriften, auf Online-Seiten, die sehen Videos und die sehen einfach, es blinkt, die Leute haben Spaß. Es ist auch einfach, wenn man sich das anguckt, faszinierend.
Ja, es ist eben das große Nerd-Weihnachtsfest letztlich.
Und, äh, die wollen alle kommen. Und es sind einfach mehr, als in dieses Haus reinpasst. Also, wir waren ja früher in Berlin, da waren es, glaube ich, so 3.000, 3.500 Leute. Oder auch mal dann irgendwie ein 5.000. Dann ist es schon echt aus allen Nähten geplatzt. Und dann sind wir halt nach Hamburg, da war es größer. Und dann ist es innerhalb von jedem Jahr so unheimlich gewachsen, dass wir irgendwie nach zwei oder drei Jahren schon wieder ausverkauft waren. Das war der Hammer. Weil einfach die Leute immer mehr über den CCC mitbekommen, durch auch so schöne Sachen wie hier dieses Chaosradio. Und einfach sagen, ich will da mal vorbeigehen, ich will mir das angucken, ich will sehen, wer das ist, was die machen. Und ich will vor allem in Kontakt mit denen kommen. Und ja, dann haben wir halt das Problem, dass mich leider nicht jeder, der kommen möchte, ein Ticket abkriegt. Und so ganz stimmt das auch noch nicht, dass es keine Tickets mehr gibt. Denn wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe, gibt es morgen noch mal eine Verkaufsrunde.
Früh ist um zehn.
Um Gottes willen.
Also quasi mitten in der Nacht.
Für so was muss man dann immer Opfer bringen und früh aufstehen.
Ich habe sogar schon von Leuten gehört, die sich da für einen Tag frei nehmen.
Dann versucht man halt noch ein Ticket zu bekommen. Und ich kann da einen Daumen drücken.
Sagen viele Leute, die nicht wissen, worum es geht. Das heißt, man geht dann früh um zehn irgendwo hin oder man auf eine Webseite.
Und dann klickt man und hofft, dass man unter den ersten ist. Also mittlerweile gibt es da sozusagen dann eine Schlange, in die man sich virtuell anstellt. Da kriegt man eine Nummer.
Unter tickets.events.ccc.de im Übrigen.
Genau. Und dann kriegt man halt eine Nummer und dann rückt man nach und nach nach. Also die Leute kaufen auch verschieden viele Tickets und irgendwann sind dann alle weg und bis zu irgendeinem Punkt der Schlange ist es halt gegangen, genauso wie wenn man sich irgendwo anstellt und Tickets kaufen möchte. Da weiß man ja auch nicht, wie viele jetzt jeder vor einem kauft, ob eins oder drei oder irgendwas.
Was kann man denn noch daran teilnehmen, wenn man kein Ticket mehr bekommt?
Das gibt es irgendwie aufs Mit überall, everywhere.
Es gibt unterschiedliche Hacker Spaces, also so Räume, Örtlichkeiten, wo viel gebastelt wird, die das ganze Livestreamen und die partizipieren und die haben VPNs zu uns und so weiter und so weiter.
Zum einen kann man virtueller Teil des Kongressnetzes werden, das haben unsere Netzwerkejungs das sogenannte NOC, Network Operation Center, immer geschaffen und das ist immer ganz vorteilhaft, wenn man Sachen probieren will, die sonst eigentlich nur vor Ort gehen, netzmäßig. Die andere und die andere viel wichtigere Sache ist, zusammen streamen gucken, wenn man in so ein Huxbase geht. Da gibt es derer verschiedene in Deutschland. Normalerweise gibt es auf events.ccc.de dann immer noch noch ein Wiki, wo das alles aufgelistet ist. Das wird es wahrscheinlich auch dieses Jahr wieder geben. Schaut euch einfach mal um nach dem Stichwort Chaos Everywhere.
Ja genau und die die einfachste Möglichkeit ist auch einfach, also man muss jetzt auch nicht unbedingt irgendwo hingehen. Man kann auch einfach, wenn man möchte, zu Hause auf seiner Couch sitzen und sich da reinklicken. Weil dieses Streaming, was jetzt schon erwähnt wurde, was man auch gemeinsam gucken kann in den Hacker Spaces, kann man natürlich auch einfach zu Hause sich anmachen und dann statt Netflix einfach mal Talks gucken.
Oder statt die Weihnachtszeiten mit der Verwandtschaft verbringen. Wäre ich in der Stelle vorsichtig, würde ich auch sehr diplomatisch nur gegenüber der Verwandtschaft formulieren.
Kein Problem, da macht man auch für die Verwandtschaft eben den Stream auf dem Fernseher an.
Da kann man ja sozusagen die Vorträge gucken. Also da gibt es ja sehr viele, aber kann man sagen, worum geht es denn dieses Jahr?
Ich glaube, mit einem Wort kann man das definitiv nicht.
Aber gibt es sozusagen eine Art Schwerpunkt, weil man sagt, ok, dieses Jahr geht es schon in die Richtung Kopfhörer, die uns belauschen.
Also das Motto ist Works for me. Was heißt das?
Das hört sich aber für mich so an, wie wir waren zu faul, uns ein Motto auszudenken. Ganz im Gegenteil. Also die Idee hinter Works for me ist nicht, also es ist wieder ein Spiel mit einer Doppeldeutlichkeit natürlich. Auf der einen Seite läuft dieses Englische, aber auf der anderen Seite ist Works for me auch so ein bisschen so ein saloper Ausdruck, den einem ein Entwickler entgegenwirft, wenn man sagt, deine Software ist aber kaputt.
Ja, aber sie läuft doch auf meinem Rechner.
Genau, es läuft doch bei mir. Das heißt, so ein bisschen diese Idee, ich habe so meine Sphäre und in dieser Sphäre funktioniert alles. Das kann kulturell sein, das kann, wie jetzt, wo es ursprünglich herkommt, rein technisch sein. So dieses, in meiner Welt ist alles heile. Wenn du ein Problem mit meiner Software, mit meiner Welt hast, dann ist es bei dir kaputt. Das ist ja nicht meine Schuld.
Natürlich meinen wir das jetzt nicht ernst, sondern das ist natürlich sarkastisch, ironisch. Was ist jetzt wieder die richtige Form?
Eine Überlegungsanregung.
Genau, davon wollen wir weg. Also genau von dieser Haltung, die einfach viele haben, die sagen, das ist doch nicht mein Problem, warum soll ich mich damit beschäftigen? Wir haben das ja schon gehört damals bei Vorratsdatenspeicherung, ich habe nichts zu verstecken, das ist nicht mein Problem irgendwie. Dann irgendwie Mening sitzt im Knast. Ja, ich sitze ja nicht im Knast, das ist ja nicht mein Problem. Also man hat immer wieder ganz viele Leute in der Allgemeinheit, die sagen, ja betrifft mich nicht, mein Leben ist gut.
Genau, das hatten wir auch schon als Motto. Also das steht in der Tradition von not my department oder gated communities, gerade im letzten Jahr.
Und hier ist es noch ein bisschen weiter, so es geht mich nicht an, sondern für mich ist das okay. Und das geht auch so ein bisschen fähig, wo viele sagen, sich sozusagen aufregen hier, die Situation ist für Flüchtlinge schlecht, für Frauen in irgendwelchen Bereichen oder dies oder jenes und sagen, na ja, also für mich funktioniert das aber so, wie es ist total gut. Warum sollen wir was ändern? Fänd ich doof. Statt eben da ein bisschen größer. Und darauf soll halt aufmerksam gemacht werden, dass man einfach mal überdenkt. Ja, schön, dass das für dich funktioniert. Aber wie sieht es denn für den Rest der Welt aus? Sollte man das nicht ändern, damit es für alle gut funktioniert?
Jetzt, wo das gerade sozusagen darum geht, es geht um alle. Es wird ja gerade diskutiert oder es scheint eine Diskussion zu geben. Also Erdgeist, jemand, der auch schon häufig im Chaosradio war, hat einen Artikel geschrieben, darüber, dass es anscheinend sozusagen bei manchen Leuten so eine Meinung gibt, wie naja, irgendwie, was wollen diese ganzen Fremden auf dem Kongress? Das sind doch alles gar keine echten Hacker. Ist das sozusagen, ist es eine Diskussion, die wirklich stattfindet? Oder sind das verirrte Einzeltäter?
Oder wie ist da die Stimmung?
Diese Stimmen kommen immer mal wieder auf. In meinem Umkreis muss ich jetzt sagen, eher vereinzelt. Aber natürlich gerade eben im Zusammenhang mit Ticket sind ausverkauft oder sind sehr schnell weg und stehen jetzt kurz davor, ausverkauft zu sein, ist dann immer die Sache, ich habe kein Ticket bekommen, aber da kommen Leute, die sind gar keine Hacker, aber ich bin da oder hier, der und der Hacker und der hat gar kein Ticket bekommen und Schweinerei war sollen denn die ganzen da. Und meine Meinung ist, dass das nicht wirklich der Wahrheit entspricht. Also, weil ich mein, dieses Jahr wurde ja beim Ticketverkauf auch die Möglichkeit gegeben, dass Leute, die zum Beispiel Engel waren, also Helfer im letzten Jahr, sogenannte Tokens bekommen haben, ebenso auch Speaker oder andere Leute, die eben Teil wesentlicher Teams waren, damit der Kongress auch funktioniert, damit die dabei sind, damit eben der Kongress auch im nächsten Jahr funktioniert. Und es gab auch die Möglichkeit, über Hacker-Spaces vorher Tickets zu beziehen. Das heißt, man musste eigentlich nur irgendwo jemand kennen, Kontakt haben, fragen und hat dann so einen Token bekommen, um sich vorher ein Ticket zu kaufen.
Also im Endeffekt, wenn man Hacker ist, weiß man, wie man ein Ticket bekommt.
Genau, aber dann kann man eigentlich sagen, wenn man irgendwie Kontakt zu den Leuten hat, dann sollte man jemanden kennen. Darüber kriegt man ein Ticket und damit kommt man auf den Kongress. Das wurde in diesem Jahr sozusagen schon adressiert, weil wir einfach das Problem hatten, dass Leute wirklich kein Ticket abbekommen haben, die aber wesentlich für die Funktion des Kongresses sind, die einfach sich ums Netzwerk kümmern, ums Video oder so. Wir sagen, okay, wir brauchen die da.
Ja, aber sagen wir, ist das wirklich eingesogt, weil die... Also ich habe ja, also ich erlebe den Kongress auch schon seit ein paar Jahren und ich finde es für mich, weil ich jetzt natürlich auch selber nicht so der Elite Hacker bin, eine totale Bereicherung, dass da ein großer Ort entsteht, wo so ganz viele Leute zusammenkommen und sagen so, hey, ihr seid alle willkommen, wichtig ist nur, dass ihr euch interessiert und dann könnt ihr mal gucken. Das empfinde ich ja als totale Bereicherung.
Aber das scheint dann nicht überall so zu sein, oder?
Also muss man jetzt Angst haben, dass... Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich erlebe das hauptsächlich, oder ich habe es jetzt hauptsächlich so richtig krass erst über Twitter erlebt und erlebe das hauptsächlich als, ich sag mal so, als Shitstorm im Nachgang dieser Ticket-Debatte, dass ich, ich habe kein Ticket bekommen und deswegen seid ihr alle doof. So ein bisschen ist vielleicht ein bisschen vereinfacht, da mag noch ein bisschen mehr hinterstehen, aber das deckt sich halt nicht mit dem, was ich so im realen Leben erlebe. Da gibt es andere Debatten.
Das ist aber eine Umstellung. Also wir machen seit, ich bin jetzt seit über zehn Jahren beim Kongress und das hat sich verändert, also wie halt die Gesellschaft dort hat sich verändert. Früher waren es wirklich ganz einzig und einzig nur Hacker und jetzt sind es mittlerweile halt auch Hacker und Familien und das müssen halt auch. Genau und das ja und Transgender und okay. Ja genau. Wir müssen auch miteinander lernen, dass sich das dieses Umfeld halt verändert, dass da auch mehr Leute reinkommen, die vielleicht noch nicht so viel Ahnung haben, so wie ich vor 13, 14 Jahren. Das verstehen manche nicht.
Und es ist ja einfach so Technik und diese ganzen Themen, womit sich der Chaos Computer Club beschäftigt, rücken halt immer mehr in den Alltag. Es kommt immer näher dran. Die Leute interessieren sich da mehr und natürlich sind dann auch solche Veranstaltungen zu den Themen immer interessanter. Sie kommen auch immer mehr in die Medien, die Leute hören davon, die wollen hinkommen. Und ich denke, das ist etwas, viele sagen halt, wir wollen wieder zurück zum alten Kongress, wo wir eben wirklich dieses Jahresversammlung sozusagen des Chaos Computer Clubs hatten, wo es wirklich nur um uns ging, wo wir zusammen hockten. Und das ist der Kongress nicht mehr. Da hat sich einfach weiterentwickelt. Es ist so ein bisschen das Aushängeschild geworden. Es ist für mich eigentlich eine unserer Öffentlichkeitsveranstaltungen geworden, wo wir einfach zeigen, wer der CCC ist und was es ist. Und die Leute einfach teilnehmen können und auch einen Einstieg finden können in diese Welt. Aber es ist ja nicht so, als wäre das die einzige Veranstaltung im Chaosumfeld. Es gibt noch ganz, ganz viele Veranstaltungen. Es gibt einfach neue Veranstaltungen, die diesen familiären Charakter haben, wo halt vor allem die Hacker, die Nerds aus der Szene eben hinkommen und sich treffen. Und das ist für mich einfach so ein Generationswechsel. So ein bisschen. Also auch von diesen Veranstaltungen. Die entwickeln sich weiter und man muss da immer ein bisschen schauen, was wird da raus. Und das ist halt gerade als Softwareentwickler, was doch viele von uns sind, ist das was, was wir eigentlich kennen. Und in der Softwareentwicklung gibt es auch so was, das nennt sich Retrospektiven. Das heißt, man soll regelmäßig betrachten und zurückschauen, wie haben sich eigentlich Dinge verändert und kann ich alles noch genauso beihalten, wie es ist oder muss ich Dinge ändern in meinem Prozess, in meinem von meinen Sachen? Und das ist was, was hier einfach auch einfach mal nötig ist, zu reflektieren und zu überlegen, was ist der Kongress eigentlich geworden und wo wollen wir damit hin? Und ja, das ist halt in den letzten Jahren war das erst mal größer werden und Wachstum.
Okay, und jetzt würde ich doch noch mal gerne wissen, was passiert da inhaltlich bei den ganzen Vorträgen. Also ich meine, es gibt ja sozusagen, es gibt noch nicht das Programm, also wann welcher Vortrag stattfindet, aber man kann schon sehen, welche Vorträge es geben wird. Ihr habt doch bestimmt schon einmal reingeguckt. Ich will jetzt von jedem von euch ein wissen, wer jetzt okay, das ist ein Vortrag, interessiert mich, den finde ich vielleicht gut. Also ich habe spontan einen Vortrag im Kopf noch, da ging es darum, wir haben uns, da muss ich jetzt gerade mal ein bisschen rumladen, ich probiere es zu beschränken. Jetzt wo dieser ganz große IP-Bereich in IPv6 aufgemacht wurde, der ja wirklich riesengroß ist, also man vergleicht das immer gerne mit, alle Sandkörner auf der Welt können irgendwie eine Adresse haben und da haben sie alle gesagt, wunderbar, wenn es so viele Adressen gibt, dann kann es ja garantiert niemand Bösen geben, der alle Adressen durchscannen kann und irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken finden kann, das ist viel zu viel. Und natürlich kommt da wieder irgendein Typ von der TU Berlin und sagt, ja, hier, da, hab da. Also da will jemand das ganze neue Internet scannen, das ist viel größer als früher. Er will quasi die Körner in der Nüge erzählen. Nein, nein, er will nicht erzählen. Er hat. Okay, Carina.
Ja, also mein Favorit ist eigentlich ein ganzer Track, den es neu gibt, nämlich den Space Track, also ein Thema, das ist irgendwie ein ziemlicher Hype. Seit den letzten Jahren schon in dieser Nerdszene irgendwie ist es dieses ganze Thema Raumfahrt. Und da kommt der aktuelle Vorsitzende der ESA, der European Space Agency und ja, oder Director ist eigentlich das richtige Wort und hält einen Vortrag über den Mond und das European Space Exploration Programm. Also einfach das, nachdem wir jetzt uns ja eigentlich von dem Mond so ein bisschen abgewandt haben, das aber aktuell ist, was wir uns wieder mehr angucken. Und ja, das ist halt der Herr Wörner, der war auch vorher der Vorstandsvorsitzende des DLR, also des Deutschen Forschungszentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt. Und ja, da bin ich einfach sehr gespannt, weil das ist einfach mal was ganz Neues auf dem Kongress und gerade auch diese über diese Mischung von Wissenschaft und Raumfahrtbetrieb und Hacken, das finde ich passt einfach extrem gut zusammen.
Aber du arbeitest ja auch da, oder?
Ich arbeite beim DLR, daher ist das sozusagen mein früherer hoher Chef und dadurch ist das natürlich anwesenheitspflicht für mich.
Macht ihr, dann sorgt ihr auch dafür, dass der nächste Marsland dann nicht wieder wegen deiner Softwarefehlers abstürzt?
Wir geben uns alle Mühe.
Sehr gut. Matthias?
Ja, Space und Wissenschaft bringt mich auch im Prinzip direkt zu meinem wahrscheinlich favorisierten Talk. Das wird in diesem Jahr, so wie wahrscheinlich auch letztes Jahr, wieder methodisch inkorrekt werden. Der sozusagen die Show gewordene Version des großartigen Podcasts von Nikolas Wurl und Reinhard Remfordt und die werden wahrscheinlich wieder eine großartige Show auf die Bühne bringen und es wird mit Sicherheit wieder Feuer.
Also wir können dort abreißen. Das ist die letzte Sache, die im MCCH stattfindet, der Kongress. Ich habe gehört, wir müssen Besen rein übergeben. Das heißt, es ist aber nicht darüber gesagt, wie viel davon in Containern hinterlandet.
Richtig, also ich bin auf jeden Fall gespannt, was die Jungs da auf die Bühne stellen werden. Es wird auf jeden Fall sehr unterhaltsam werden.
Gut, Sokrates?
Ja, ich bin da sehr zerrissen. Das Problem ist, ich will eigentlich ganz viele, aber das, was mich am meisten interessieren wird, wird die Infrastructure Review sein. Heißt? Die gesamte Infrastruktur, also das Netzwerk, das WLAN, wie viele Clients und so weiter, wo die ganz tiefen Nerds aus dem NOC, aus dem POC, aus der Seidenstraße berichten, was sie denn so alles geschaufelt haben an Daten von A nach B, von C nach D und wie die ausgesehen haben, aber nicht was drin war.
Also, das heißt, muss man wirklich sagen, zum Chaos Communication Congress wird ein Netzwerk im CCH aufgebaut und das ist dann irgendwie der größte Datenknoten in Europa, oder was? Ja, wir hatten vor Jahr und Tag, als wir noch in Berlin waren, mehr Anbindung des Kongresszentrums, als es zur damaligen Zeit in ganz Afrika zu ganz Afrika gab. Das war schon... Wird das WLAN funktionieren? Wenn jetzt jemand sozusagen dahin geht zum ersten Mal und sein Computer mitbringen will und Angst hat, oh nein, da sind ja viele böse Hacker, die machen bestimmt mein Computer kaputt. Sollen wir den mitbringen oder sollen wir lieber zu Hause lassen?
Also den eigentlichen, den man immer benutzt, auf gar keinen Fall. Und wenn dann auf jeden Fall, hat man ein Backup.
Oder eine frische Installation und nach dem Kongress einfach wieder alles platt machen, neu installieren und kreativ lege tut eh gut, sicher sein.
Keine wichtigen Daten darauf haben.
Man sollte halt gucken, dass man alles auf ein aktuelles System hat, also vorher alle Updates einspielen. Man sollte gucken, dass man nur verschlüsselt surft, weil alles, was unverschlüsselt ist, wird halt einfach mitgelesen. Das ist immer eine gute Empfehlung, unabhängig von Kongress oder nicht. Mein Empfehlung ist eh, es gibt so viel Programm und so viel zu tun, sich da jetzt hinter seinem Laptop zu verkriechen, das ist gar nicht so schlau. Vielleicht ist es cleverer, ein Tablet oder so etwas mitzunehmen, wo man eben mal den Fahrplan nachgucken kann, also das Programm und ein paar andere Informationen. Das kann man eigentlich sehr schön, einfach ein frisches Android drauf, nur die Service und Passwörter angeben oder Dienste anmelden, die man wirklich, wirklich braucht. Nichts, wo irgendwie die Kreditkarte vielleicht noch hinterhängt. Und Passwörter danach einfach einmal neu setzen. Das ist eh immer eine gute Sache. Und dann kann man das eigentlich anfangen, dass die Hand das einmal alle neu setzen. Und dann ist man eigentlich auch ganz, ganz gut.
Genau, wenn man sich das mal zurechtgelegt hat, dann kann man das direkt zur Routine werden lassen.
Genau, und es ist auch gar nicht so schlecht, einfach mal drei Tage im Jahr mal nicht E-Mails zu checken.
Na, ob ihr das schafft, ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich werde jetzt auch zum Kongress fahren und werde euch beobachten und gucken, ob ihr ja auch alle eure Geräte nicht gerade in der Hand haltet und drauf guckt. So, wir haben jetzt heute viel geschafft hier im Chaosradio Nummer 229. Ich wollte trotzdem noch fragen, ganz zum Schluss, haben wir noch ein Thema vergessen, wo wir gesagt, das haben wir nicht mehr geschafft, aber sollten wir heute vielleicht wenigstens mal hinterherklicken?
Also ein Thema nicht, aber eine kleine Ankündigung haben wir noch. Und zwar findet am 13.12. der im CCCB, also dem Chaos Computer Club Berlin, der nächste Datengarten statt. Das ist ein Dienstag.
Und für diesen Datengarten haben wir uns etwas ganz Besonderes ausgedacht, und zwar Lightning Talks. Und zwar könnt ihr da innerhalb von ungefähr einen zehnminütigen Vortrag einreichen und ihn bei uns einfach mal auf unserer Bühne präsentieren.
Und wir streamen das Ganze. Wir haben genügend Live Publikum. Themenbeschränkungen? Ja, nein, kommt mit allem, was ihr wollt. Hauptsache zehn Minuten.
Also es wäre gut, wenn ihr das Thema bei uns vorher einreicht.
Genau, also prinzipiell sind wir relativ frei. Ob wir jetzt irgendwie, weiß nicht, was über eure Flohfarben hören wollen oder so, weiß ich nicht. Aber prinzipiell machen wir halt, wenn wir viele haben, fällig eine Auswahl. Das müssen wir mal schauen. Aber eigentlich ist der Plan First Come, First Serve. Und es geht wirklich darum, eine Idee vorzustellen, ein Problem, das Lieblingstool, was irgendwas macht oder irgendwas. Das ist eben das Schöne an Lightning Talks. Hat nämlich zwei Vorteile. Man ist halt total frei. Aber für die Zuhörerinnen, wenn es halt blöd ist, ist es halt auch einfach in zehn Minuten maximal vorbei.
Okay, also entweder selber Vortrag halten im Cosco Butter Club Berlin oder vielen kleinen vorträgen Zuhören. Vielen Dank.
Und wir reden übrigens nicht über Chemtrade.
Genau. Und für mehr Informationen findet ihr da auch auf unserer Webseite www.https.berlin.ccc.de mehr Informationen. Und da findet ihr auch Möglichkeiten, dann eben euren Lightning Talk anzumelden.
Sehr gut. So wird es gemacht. Diese Sendung kann man da bestimmt auch irgendwann finden. Ich bedanke mich jetzt von Anne, nee, bei, Herr Gott, ist gleich vorbei. Sokrates, Matthias, Carina und Danimo. Vielen Dank. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Ich spreche Mikrofone und empfehle mich, normalerweise mit dem Spruch, verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups und lasst sie nicht überwachen. Aber dieses Mal gibt es noch etwas Besonderes. Und zwar normalerweise spielen wir hier einen ganz bestimmten Endtrack. Da hat sich jemand beschwert, da immer diese komische Rapper. Und außerdem gibt es das Design vom Chaos Communication Congress und eine offene Lizenz. Nicht Creative Commons, sondern do what you want, also mach mit dem Design was du willst und denk über die Frauen.